it was a beautiful September day but
Sean Taylor was trapped in his car and
one of the worst cases of gridlock he
had ever seen he tried to look on the
bright side though and while he was
stuck in an unmoving car at least he had
a Pleasant View with the wide shimmering
Lake just off the road next to him he
was admiring the scene when tiny drops
of rain started landing on his
windshield that's funny there wasn't a
cloud in the sky a moment ago there was
something off about the rain though it
looked dirty a rusty red color was that
blood he didn't have time to think about
it because just then a thick dense Mist
began to roll over the lake a fog of
blood just off the side of the road he
could see a huge silhouette rising out
of the water is that an old submarine
what Sean didn't know was that he was
about to have an encounter with
scp-1861 also known as the HMS winter
shimer a ghostly submarine with strange
and terrifying effects Sean and the
other drivers stuck in traffic that day
were far from the first people to have a
dangerous brush with this legendary
vessel according to SCP Foundation
records the HMS wintershimer has been
appearing since as early as 1916. the
first recorded incident occurred in the
British Seaside town of innsmith on sea
you won't find this town on any Maps or
in the history books and you're about to
find out why the 500 population of the
town which had already reduced by the
wartime draft into the currently raging
great world war awoke to Red Skies on
February 6 1916. citizens left their
homes to investigate only to find their
entire town had been enveloped in a
thick Red Mist the swelling Crimson
clouds up ahead began to rain showering
the town in a hail of viscous red goo
anyone unlucky enough to taste it would
say that this strange rain was a
dreadful mix of salt and copper this was
because as the foundation would later
determine the rain and fog was a
disgusting combination of salt water
human blood and human cerebrospinal
fluid but the real threat was Rising
just beyond the beach technically
speaking the HMS winter shimer vessel is
designated as
scp-1861-a it appears to be a World War
One era British b-class submarine
designed by Vickers for the Royal Navy
in 1904. by 1916 this particular type of
boat was already on its way to being
Obsolete and were largely deployed in
Malta far from the active fronts so one
of these vessels appearing on an
otherwise unremarkable stretch of
English Coastline should have been a
clue that something was terribly wrong
but the poor residents of innsmith on
sea didn't know the half of it soon
figures in what appeared to be archaic
diving gear began emerging from the
winter shimer and made their way into
the township they seemed terrified
running up to and frantically screaming
at any local they could find please
listen to me something terrible is about
to happen here we need you to come with
us or you're all going to die you must
believe us the locals were frightened by
what they heard they'd been listening to
news reports of the Great War unfolding
across the globe for two years now had
it finally come to them they pictured
shells raining down from the sky
decimating their defenseless little town
in a rain of fire the Navy must have
been brought in to save them before the
German bombardment began while some took
more convincing than others the men in
diving suits known as
scp-1861-b eventually managed to
persuade the entire town to join them
and lead the townspeople down to the
water one by one they were all boarded
onto the submarine hundreds of them many
couldn't believe their eyes as they
watched scores of people disappear in
front of them into the dark bowels of
the wintershimer where were they all
going how would they all fit in there
but it was too late for any of them to
back out now the vessel submerged once
more and everyone was gone the entire
population of innsmith on sea had
disappeared in a rain of fog and blood
never to be seen again the foundation
wiped all records of the town from
existence and delivered appropriate
amnestic treatment to anyone who still
mentioned or Remembered in Smith on sea
the fate of those who board the HMS
winter shimer is always the same vanish
from the face of the Earth explained
Away by the foundation as accidental
death by extreme weather event there
have been hundreds of documented
sightings of
scp-1861 and the anomalous weather event
can occur near any body of water wide
enough to accommodate
scp-1861-a's comms Tower and topmost
platform depth does not seem to be any
hindrance of the submarine appearing and
it can even manifest in water that's
just a few inches deep as Sean and the
other unfortunate victims of the rush
hour traffic were being powered and
thick red droplets from above a crimson
Mist rolled in between the cars Sean had
heard of so-called freak weather events
before like raining frogs and fish but
this was something different and it
frightened him he could see now that the
silhouette rising from the lake really
was an old submarine and he watched as a
legion of mysterious figures disembarked
from the vessel and began spilling onto
the road the men in ancient looking
diving suits walked among the cars and
one of them approached Sean's car he
began tapping frantically on the window
and Sean could tell he was yelling
something Sean was scared and more but
more than anything else he was confused
against his better judgment he rolled
down the window just a crack to hear
what the man was saying his British
accented voice muted by the diving suit
the man frantically told him duh please
listen to me on Lieutenant Samuel Ramsay
of the HMS wintershimer we're evacuating
the Ariah please you've got to come with
me we're in danger out here HMS Sean
thought isn't that what they call all
British ships what was a British
submarine doing in the middle of a lake
in the United States through his
windshield Sean could already see other
men in diving suits leading people from
the cars out towards the submarine
something had to be going on here
something big Lieutenant Ramsey was
still banging away at the glass of
Sean's window becoming increasingly
agitated so if you won't comply with my
orders I'm within my rights to take you
by force for your own safety Sean could
feel the fear setting in but he didn't
know what else to do he turned off the
car and took off his seatbelt he was
just about to open the door when there
was a tap on the passenger side window
of his car it was a soldier in what
looked to be Advanced tactical gear
there were several soldiers directing
cars to drive on the shoulder to get
around the mess of stopped automobiles
Sean looked to his left and the Man in
the diving suit was gone the soldier
tapped again and Sean didn't need to be
told twice he followed his directions
and drove around the traffic jam and out
of the Mist a half mile down the road
Sean was stopped by another group of
soldiers and given an amnestic he drove
away never knowing how close he had come
to Vanishing in the bowels of SCP
1861-a Sean was lucky that one of the
SCP foundation's mobile task forces had
taken over the situation but they were
too late to help those who had already
complied with
scp-1861-b's orders and boarded the
winter shimer the task force made it
their business to save whoever they
could but that wasn't their only
directive the foundation had recorded a
huge number of
scp-1861 instances since 1916 and now
they were finally going to figure out
what was going on inside the foundation
had already discovered that those taken
onto the winter shimer don't simply
disappear once on board the submarine
they are forced into a diving suit of
their own which transforms them into new
instances of
scp-1861-b upon realizing this
Foundation scientists advised an
ingenious plot six months before this
latest instance of 1861 the foundation
dispatched two members of d-class
personnel who were familiar with one
another into the Red Mist one was
instructed not to interact with
scp-1861-b while the other named Sal was
ordered to enter the submarine his
mission was to report back all findings
to Foundation researcher Dr clutch
during the next 1861 event the d-class
who remained on Shore was brought in
Once More by the mobile task force
during the September event that Sean
witnessed they checked each diving suit
wearing anomaly until they heard a
familiar voice muffled by The Mask it
was Sal and he'd been transformed into
an instance of
scp-1861-b the human d-class receiving
questions from Dr clutch via a remote
broadcast commenced the interview of his
former friend it is from this vital
interview that much of the foundation's
knowledge of the mysterious HMS
wintershimer is drawn Accord according
to Sal the interior of the winter shimer
which is a long narrow passageway is a
spatial anomaly that seems to stretch on
forever this explains how vast number of
people like the entire population of
innsmith on sea can disappear into the
submarine at once Sal reported that
about an hour after entering the vessel
the hatch closed and the interior began
rapidly filling with water as the
submarine descended prisoners of the
winter shimer were faced with two
choices suit up or drown few chose the
latter option and as soon as the suit
was on the transformation had begun as
soon as everyone was suited up and the
submarine had fully descended causing
the 1861 weather event to dissipate on
Earth the winter shimer had effectively
entered an alternate Dimension the
airlock opened and the new recruits were
instructed to step outside and take a
look around the wintersheimer veterans
informed the new Sailors that everyone
on land was likely already dead by this
point when Sal first exited the
submarine he commented on everything
around him looking eerily similar to how
it looked on land before the Mist
descended but with one key difference it
seemed as though everything was
underwater well not quite that it was
almost as though everything was water
like the world had taken on a kind of
flowing liquid state Sal and the others
existed in this otherworldly land of
Living Water for six months and as the
months passed things only got stranger
they found that they neither needed to
eat nor sleep according to Sal all they
did was breathe and pass the time by
exploring and talking to one another
anyone who attempted to take off their
suit would dissolve and diffuse into the
same liquid that surrounded them Dr
clutch asked Sal about the other
inhabitants of this alien realm and this
was when things got truly disturbing
there were dead humans and animals
floating all over the place missing
their eyes as though they'd been scooped
out and missing their mouths as though
they'd been bitten out of their face by
some kind of huge Predator their empty
eye sockets bled constantly and Sal
theorized that this may have something
to do with the anomalous blood Mists of
scp-1861 when asked to provide more
information on why all the corpses were
mutilated in this way Sal said that one
of his superiors on the wintershamer
told him the Watcher of eyes and biter
of teeth deemed them worthy whatever
this mysterious being was it seemed to
be a powerful figure with an 1861's
Water World and Sal felt lucky that he
never had a direct run-in with the
creature himself for his final request
Dr clutch asked Sal to attempt to remove
his suit the foundation had learned in
previous instances of 1861 that the
diving suits have anomalous durability
and it was impossible for anyone other
than the wearer to remove them hence why
the foundation could never deal with
1861-b by using Brute Force naturally
clutch was in interested in finding out
what was going on underneath Sal
expressed fear and anxiety at first
wondering if after all he'd been through
whether he could ever be considered
human anymore eventually he was
convinced to remove the suit and his
worst fears were confirmed the second
Sal removed his helmet gallons of
seawater poured out and the now empty
suit collapsed to the ground Sal's body
was never found only some teeth and a
pair of eyes were recovered the eyes
were later confirmed to be belonging to
a young girl and the teeth were
identified as having come from a
European Red Deer and so the dark
mystery of the HMS winter shimer
continues because of the unpredictable
nature of its appearances and the
resulting difficulty of containing it
the winter shimer has earned a ketter
classification the only containment
procedure currently employed by the SCP
Foundation is for mobile task forces to
try and intercept the submarine when
appearances are reported and hopefully
prevent or at least reduce the a
kidnapping of civilians with so many
questions left unanswered all we can say
for certain is that if a Red Mist ever
descends on you and a stranger in a
diving suit tells you you're in grave
danger he's absolutely right did you
ever have to perform a dissection in
school maybe you had to carve up a fetal
pig or slice into a frog while
nightmarish visions of Kermit and a
widowed Miss Piggy danced in your head
though it's rarely a pleasant experience
unless your tastes are on The Morbid
side most biology teachers would agree
that the best way to learn how something
works is to take it apart as distasteful
as it can be to hold a frog's tiny liver
in your hands it definitely does give
you a better sense of the pieces that
make up the complete creature but what
if there was an easier way to look at
the individual parts of a living being
what if you could take it apart without
ever having to prep a scalpel or stain
your hands with the blood of innocent
frogs like most of the seemingly
impossible things in our world the SCP
Foundation discovered something that
allows its users to do just that in fact
it can handle a lot more than just a
frog and its applications go far beyond
the confines of a high school science
lab
scp-291 is a small plane steel building
with a large door on one side the door
has no handle or knob and functions
similarly to a garage door the door
cannot be pried open by any ordinary
means and the inside of scp-291 can only
be accessed if the structure is
connected to a suitable power source
once a power source has been connected
the door races and exposes a room inside
it is small about four by two meters it
contains a console board a large screen
and a Plexiglas container resembling a
coffin how very Sinister the coffin is
large enough to contain a human under
seven feet tall so sorry Ferdinand the
cannibal you're going to need to sit
this one out the coffin sits on a
conveyor belt with several tubes
connected to the wall above it on the
opposite side of the room there are
holes of varying sizes each containing a
small door that can be opened or closed
because initial observation indicated
that scp-291 was intended for some kind
of human testing a d-class test subject
was selected for experimentation the
subject was instructed to lie down in
the coffin and wait to see what would
happen next the display screen lit up
depicting a grid lined image of the test
subject buttons along the console board
adjusted the image showing the skin
muscles and organ systems of the person
in the coffin there were no words or
numbers on the screen and all of the
buttons appeared to have only two
settings on and off when one of the
researchers pressed the first button on
the console the tubes above the coffin
began pouring a blue liquid into it the
test subject reacted with confusion but
did not experience any adverse effects
they quickly lost Consciousness
indicating that the liquid was some sort
of sedative the liquid continued to pour
into the coffin until the vessel was
completely filled at which point it
congealed into a thick gel the test
subject's breathing and heartbeat slowed
to a stop and the conveyor belt suddenly
creaked to life the coffin was carried
test subject inside through a small door
that immediately locked behind it the
small room was filled with the sounds of
Gears turning Machinery clinking and
Motors whirring the display screen was
taken over by a large rectangle
resembling a traditional loading screen
after 30 minutes the process was
complete and the back door of the room
unlocked itself when the researcher
walked through the back door they found
another room with a conveyor belt and a
row of two dozen lockers each Locker was
open one at a time and its contents
removed for examination inside each the
research team found a different portion
of the test subject's body in a block of
some unidentified clear substance the
body was divided in the lockers into
these separate parts brain lungs and
diaphragm art digestive system
reproductive organs left eye right eye
upper left torso and arm upper right
torso and arm lower left torso and upper
leg lower right torso and upper leg
lower left leg and foot lower right leg
and foot lower left arm and hand lower
right arm and hand neck and head upper
skeletal system lower skeletal system
lymphatic and circulatory system and
skin
the miracle of the human body right
boundless in its fascinating
complexities each block of body parts
was placed back in its designated locker
and the second button on the console was
pressed at this point the doors to the
organ lockers sealed themselves shut and
the sound of the Machinery working
filled the small space once again this
continued for a duration of
approximately 45 minutes when the
Machinery went silent a new Plexiglas
coffin emerged into the main room with
the test subject inside he looked
identical to how he had looked at the
start of the experiment with no evidence
that he had previously been disassembled
the blue blue liquid slowly evaporated
from the container and the test subject
opened his eyes the lead researcher
conducted an immediate interview with
the reassembled subject who reported no
memory of the process after initial
exposure to the blue liquid they
insisted that the process had been like
a good night's sleep which honestly
makes us pretty eager to take it for a
spin a medical examination determined
that there were only a few changes to
the test subject during the disassembly
and reassembly when they returned to
Consciousness the test subject's stomach
was empty they were naked and all of
their hair was Gone with this new
understanding of scp-291's anomalous
properties the foundation decided to
continue their experimentation with each
new test the experiments became more
creative and unsurprisingly more
depraved first a d-class subject was
placed in the coffin and disassembled
then instead of placing the various body
parts in their designated lockers the
vital organs were removed from their
storage before reassembly was attempted
this resulted in the equipment shutting
down completely a researcher pressed the
third button which forced a hard reset
of the entire process causing all the
blocks of body parts to eject via an
exit hatch during the next experiment
non-vital organs were removed before the
subject's body was reassembled the
appendix and gallbladder were left out
and when the subject regained
Consciousness these organs were still
gone however there was no visible damage
or scar tissue in their place they were
simply gone as if they have never been
there in the first place so if body
parts could be removed from a test
subject could new body parts be added
could existing body parts be replaced
with different ones a d-class subject in
need of a skin graft following a
flamethrower-based accident was placed
in scp-291 once taken apart a portion of
healthy skin donated by another somewhat
unwilling d-class subject was placed in
the locker along with the skin already
present there once the subject was put
back together the healthy skin had
replaced the damaged skin with no
adverse effects repeat attempts at this
test showed that it was effective for
limb transplants heart transplants and
kidney transplants with a zero percent
failure rate across all tests after
determining that scp-291 could be used
for an Untold amount of good making
organ donations easier and safer than
ever the foundation naturally had to
Pivot to something more useless but
interesting and likely horrifying after
all it's not like they could ever just
make anomalous technology available to
the public right two d-class subjects
one man and one woman were disassembled
by scp-291 the brains of the test
subjects were swapped and then they were
reassembled when they awoke the subjects
had the personalities and memories of
the brain placed in their body in a turn
of events previously only seen in
blockbuster comedies like Freaky Friday
and the live-action Scooby-Doo movie
seminal piece of Cinema the subjects had
swapped bodies they were subsequently
disassembled their request us to look at
their new bodies naked having been
swiftly denied and the brains were
returned to their rightful bodies after
the experiment was finished the subjects
appeared mostly normal however they did
complain of disorientation as well as
mental and physical discomfort over the
next several days after going through
two brain transplants in one day though
that's really the least you can expect
after perfecting the practice of
swapping body parts between different
human subjects the ghoulishly Curious
research team decided to take things in
an inter-species Direction a variety of
test subjects including cats dogs
lizards fish mice and of course humans
were selected for this next round of
experiments 20 tests were performed
using these new subjects and only three
of the experiments were successful in
transferring body parts from an animal
of one species to another animal of a
different one attempts to swap body
parts between mammals and reptiles or
fish proved disastrous when a fish and a
human were both disassembled bolt and
the fish's gills were placed with the
human's body parts neither creature
survived the reassembly process the
human awoke with a new set of gills
embedded in their neck and immediately
began gasping for the oxygen they could
not take in within minutes they had
suffocated the fish's fate was even
worse it did not reassemble so much as
it became a pile of goo scales and two
floating eyeballs experimentation with a
human and a lizard yielded similar
results turning the lizard into a puddle
of organic matter and killing the human
test subject after only a few minutes as
disastrous as the failed cross species
tests were the successful ones were
almost as bad trial 001 involved a cat
and a human not wanting to attempt too
much at once the research team opted to
just swap out one organ the left eye
both subjects survived the transfer and
were able to use their new eye the human
subject reported full use of the cat's
eye with improved night vision in
addition to trouble seeing color the cat
did did not enjoy its new eye nearly as
much as the human subject and had clawed
its human eye out of its head by the end
of the following week in trial 007 a
successful brain transfer was performed
between an adult human man and an
English Mastiff the man in the Mastiff's
body expressed discomfort with walking
on all fours and asked to be returned to
his body as soon as possible the mastiff
in the man's body adjusted to bipedal
locomotion in a few hours but was
disassembled after urinating on a
researcher's shoes the final successful
trial and the most unnerving was
trial016 a female d-class test subject's
reproductive organs were swapped with
those of a pregnant Labrador Retriever
an ultrasound conducted after the
transfer indicated that the labrador
fetuses survived the procedure and could
conceivably be carried to term by the
human subject several members of the
research team began to take bets on
whether or not she would end up giving
birth to puppies but the transfer was
reversed within the day so we'll never
know what exactly would have happened
perhaps that's for the best personally
we hope the foundation's Ethics
Committee gives some of these scientists
a very Stern talking to about their
behavior on this one when not in use for
testing
scp-291 is to be disconnected from any
power sources at least two Personnel are
positioned outside of its containment at
all times standing guard and these
personnel must be swapped out every week
when it is not connected to any power
sources scp-291 is considered harmless
though it should still be treated with
caution the main entryway remains closed
and locked when there is no available
power source but the door can be opened
manually from the inside in the event of
an emergency any disassembled organisms
are stored in the locker in the
containment facility labeled with a
sharpie marker in order to keep track of
what specimens are stored there whether
this is the same Sharpie used to label
food in the break room fridge is unknown
but just like Dr D Romero's ham sandwich
it's best to leave these items untouched
any Personnel found to be responsible
for missing specimens will be
transferred to another project and
receive a strongly worded email the
foundation regularly deals with
anomalies of a more Sinister nature the
most frightening among these of course
are the ones that stalk and kill
foundation operatives for no clear Rhyme
or Reason sometimes the foundation's
agents and researchers become subject to
things that seek to entrap and utterly
consume them Dr Elizabeth Graham is one
such poor soul nowadays her name is
whispered through mess halls and
cubicles since no one really seems to
know what happened to her one moment she
was carrying a stack of files between
two offices the next completely gone the
foundation security teams couldn't
figure out what happened to her the CCTV
cameras just showed her blinking out of
existence and the files falling to the
floor her biometric scanner simply
returned a dead signal it seemed that
one day Dr Graham simply cease to exist
of course the foundation isn't above
keeping secrets from its own Personnel
perhaps they did find something a series
of SCP documents covered in sand
suddenly appearing in Graham's office
one day neatly stacked and paper clipped
all signed by her in her own handwriting
and detailing her days spent in a pocket
reality of some sort it wouldn't be the
first time it had happened the infamous
red reality incident with Dr Robert
Scranton had already upset researchers
and there was no reason to alarm them
further about something they couldn't
change so Dr Graham's papers were
covered up and relegated to long-term
storage where they would likely never be
thought of again but don't you wonder
what happened to Dr Graham the first
thing Dr Graham felt when she woke up
was confusion she didn't remember
falling asleep in fact she didn't
remember much at all she had been moving
files between two offices at site-22 on
a normal work day she said hello to
Summer of her co-workers and had a late
lunch before returning to work and then
nothing the second thing she felt was
fear she looked around and realized she
was in some kind of desert a bright blue
sky was overhead and there seemed to be
a sun but all around her was sand
massive sand dunes flowing sand Plains
and even what looked like a sandstorm in
the distance but all there was was sand
Dr Graham then noticed she was still
holding some things a small falter
filled with paper clip documents pulling
one out she realized what it was a
template document for an SCP file
complete with sections for object class
containment procedures and descriptions
this place was obviously not normal but
she had been anomalously transported to
it it needed to be documented there was
nothing else to do so she sat down and
began to write she guessed at a number
who knows what SCP the foundation was on
now might as well pick something for the
middle she scrawled
scp-3890 at the top and bubbled in
ketter for the object class the
containment procedures were Spartan but
effective no effective measures of
containment were possible and she would
focus on simply exploring and finding
out what was going on then came the
description no point in sticking to the
foundation's signature clinical tone
given the circumstances it was more
important to get the information down
and so she began to transcribe her
thoughts
scp-3890 is a potentially extra
dimensional or extraterrestrial space
which I Dr Elizabeth Graham was somehow
transported to from site-22 on
21716. I'm uncertain as to whether I was
transported here due to my involvement
with the foundation after finishing the
paragraph she picked herself up off the
Sand Dune she had landed on and started
to walk in the direction of the sun she
didn't have much information and
exploring would be necessary if she was
too accurately document the anomaly it
didn't take long before she came across
something in the distance an old
collapsed Temple completely ruined from
the outside the structure sagging in on
itself it had the columns and facades of
a Roman building she noticed appearing
inside it was completely empty except
for more sand in the distance more ruins
were present some older and some more
modern office looking buildings in terms
of geography
scp-3890 takes the form of a seemingly
infinite desert plane with ruins of
differing architectural design poking
out through the sand I've noted the
presence of buildings of modern design
along with what appear to be ruins of
ancient Roman and Ericsson structures
she only noticed the first figure when
the sun started to set as the sky
shifted to Twilight she saw a person
walking casting a long Shadow excitedly
she yelled out to no response when she
approached she saw a man in an older
suit with completely lifeless eyes
stumbling along
scp-3890-1 is my Collective designation
for the humanoid entities that wander
through
scp-3890 they did not respond to any
stimuli and as far as I've been able to
tell simply walk around without a
specific destination
scp-3890-1 are either entities that have
been created to resemble humans but
imperfect or they are humans who have
been mentally altered in some way to Rob
them of their faculties there did seem
to be some kind of a day night cycle and
she didn't feel hungry or thirsty at all
though she did feel sleepy after her
first day in the desert Dr Graham
settled in one of the collapsed ruins
drifting off to sleep the second
document opens much differently this
appears to be a document for something
designated
scp-3890-2 ketter the containment
procedures are simply to always
constantly be on guard for It Whatever
It Is if Dr Graham feels something she
is approaching is not as it appears she
is to immediately Retreat the
description is a little clearer
scp-3890-2 is a living entity of varying
shape and size which resides in
scp-3890 I am uncertain as to whether
scp-3890-2 originates here or if it was
transported here at some point in the
same way I was from what I have observed
of Its Behavior it appears to be some
form of Predator
scp-3890-2 is currently hunting me I
first encountered The Entity shortly
after writing down my initial
observations of
scp-3890 it snuck up behind me while I
was resting and got me while I wasn't
paying attention I was knocked
unconscious by its attack and woke up
several hours later during the night it
had attacked me several times since that
first encounter with several hours
between each attack she was caught off
guard by it last night she hadn't
noticed its presence it seemed to just
be another building in the far off
Horizon when she sat down and pulled out
her pencil and paper again she'd started
to fill in some more information about
the humanoids they seemed to
continuously walk in circles around some
of the ruins though it was unclear to
her why or even whether they were aware
of what they were doing but when she
pulled her pencil out she heard the
buzzing in her head it was like TV
static initially soft and low but then
ramping up and quickly becoming
deafening stifling her ability to think
she looked up and she saw it for a
moment it retained its form as the
building in the Horizon but that quickly
changed he began to unfold on itself
completely black on the inside like a
dark paper crane continually folding and
unfolding stretching and compressing in
on itself by the time Dr Graham got to
her feet and ran away she began to
realize what it had done and quickly
scrawled it onto the paper
scp-3890-2 uses amnestization as a form
of attack while it has not injured me
physically thus far I've lost all memory
of significant chunks of my childhood
and early adulthood I can no longer
recall which high school I went to or
what my first job was my current
hypothesis is that as an entity it feeds
upon memory at first Dr Graham avoided
buildings and stayed to the empty parts
of the desert while walking but when the
creature appeared again unfolding out of
what seemed to be a piece of paper it
became clear what it was a mimic in the
coming hours it would pretend to be a
star a human a fly even a patch of dirt
while trying to make graham come closer
enough to consume her mind the next
document opens an even more dire
circumstances the containment procedures
have shifted drastically containment now
focuses on making sure that the mimic
does not consume any memories that Dr
Graham cannot afford to lose choose to
write down all vital memories so she can
recall them if they do get destroyed and
watch for its presence in situations and
at all times she writes the document
while huddled in a vault and a bank
dropped into
scp-3890 since it offers a little
security from the creature but the
corpses of a family in the bank imply
something less hopeful they chose to die
by their own hand rather than let the
mimic get to them Graham plans to kill
anything that tries to enter the Vault
to ensure that the mimic doesn't get in
but has bigger problems I have lost all
memories regarding how I came to be
employed by the foundation I know that I
am a foundation researcher with level 3
clearance but I simply cannot recall how
I came to be in this position many of
the SCP objects I worked with are also
missing from my memory I can tell there
is a hole there but I just don't know
what was there before her memories of
her own identity have been obliterated
who she is where she's from but the
foundation even is they have all been
taken by the mimic without fail it
manages to surprise her and consume an
important memory than dashing away as
she tries to figure out what God's
stolen from her something small like her
favorite food or her childhood bedroom
or something foundational and
fundamental like her name and her sense
of self and avoiding it isn't an option
he can pretend to be any of the single
grains of sand in the boundless desert
and Graham came to the conclusion this
is an infinite dimension of sand serving
as a hunting grounds for the mimic of
course it could be anything else too a
brick a window any of the buildings any
of the Mindless wandering people or the
clothes on Dr Graham's back any of them
could be the mimic and Graham thought of
that too it's why she hasn't let go of
her knife in days even though it's
dripping blood from examining the
corpses of the former victims of
scp-3890-2 even though she doesn't need
to eat or drink there is another concern
sleep the moment she falls asleep the
mimic will no doubt be upon on her she
hastily scribbled down a little bit more
onto the paper before trying to rest the
sun's going down I can't allow myself to
fall asleep
3890-2 will come in without a doubt if I
do I don't have to eat I don't have to
drink but I still have to sleep this
place is designed for the mimics benefit
it can hunt its prey to its heart's
content without them dying of thirst and
starvation is this an enclosure maybe
some kind of sick game my name is
Elizabeth Graham I can't forget that now
this page is my memory the next word she
writes on that paper shows something
ominous she can hear crying outside of
her makeshift shelter the next document
things have changed someone named Tony
is mentioned in the containment
procedures someone Graham trusts to take
watch while she sleeps and watches for
the mimic the descriptions explain Tony
is a child only 10 years old who fell
into this Dimension the same as Graham
when walking home from the playground
the mimic can imitate objects but it
can't speak the boy is real they've
worked on a rudimentary password system
to confirm each other's identities
regardless Graham feels almost hopeful
their chances of survival have doubled
even though they're being hunted not for
their lives but for the precious
memories inside their heads but she's
still worried about other things if
people don't starve or thirst to death
in scp-3890 do they age how long have
the Mindless humanoids been wandering
around how long has she been wandering
around though she reminds herself of her
training she also faces the fact that
she might have been exclusively picked
for a past reason I have this memory
from my childhood still everything
around it is gone but it's sort of
floating free devoid of context I'm
visiting a woman in the hospital I I
think it's a hospital and I think it's a
woman I know a close relative my mother
my grandmother I think and I go to visit
her I'm just a kid 12 I think and she
doesn't know who I am at all I don't
remember what happened before that or
after perhaps the mimic brought her here
because it knew she would hate having
her mind consumed like this but that
would mean it wasn't just intelligent
that it was sadistic and cruel she noted
down she'd asked Tony if he had a
similar experience and they'd be a
little closer to working it out the
document is hopeful Dr Graham now has
Something to Believe In the next
document is a complete mess scribblings
and squallings in the margins and the
text doesn't even begin to make any kind
of sense it's all word salad the ravings
of someone gone utterly insane she
mentions herself her own name repeatedly
and constantly but in between are
mentions of Tony the foundation the
mimic and everything in between Dr
Graham has lost her grip on reality that
or whatever wrote this wasn't Dr
Elizabeth Graham the document after that
has a very simple containment procedures
she is to kill
scp-3890-2 the mimic description I woke
up this morning Tony was gone he was the
mimic it was smarter than I thought I
guess I was stupid I should have seen
this coming but I was desperate and it
knew it all it left was some scrawled
document in a hole in my head the shape
of my name the mimic disguising itself
as a child had stolen the last thing she
had left her name all of Graham's
precautions were useless even though her
name was written down a dozen times in
the last documentation she cannot
remember it in fact when she reads it it
immediately removes itself from her mind
again not only has it taken her memory
it has taken her ability to reform them
and the documented Left Behind is one of
her own an SCP template though of course
she doesn't know what the foundation is
anymore the same document we have seen
previously in the pile yes the mimic is
learning to imitate Graham and getting
better at it maybe that's why she hasn't
been killed yet it's yet to pin down her
thought process and is waiting until it
has her perfectly memorized not that she
would know given that she's forgotten
how she even came here or when but the
mimic made a mistake it took everything
from her even her hope which has left Dr
Elizabeth Graham a woman with Nothing
Left to Lose she resolves she will not
get out of
scp-3890 the documents will probably
wind back up in Foundation possession
from some testing with an unrelated
anomaly but she will be a Mindless husk
or worse she plans to kill the mimic
it's a cowardly fearful stalker creature
and only Hunts by pretending to be other
things she knows she can take it in a
fight and she still has her knife the
next document is sober the object class
neutralized Dr Ram watched boundlessly
through the desert until the mimic
jumped for her it unfolded from a cloud
turning into a massive black origami and
lunging for her it didn't expect her to
turn around and slash outward with her
knife piercing its strange black flesh
it let out a scream shrank and Dr Graham
realized that it could feel pain so when
it lunged again she drove her knife
deeper into it before pulling back and
she repeated the process until it was a
tiny black mite in the sand and then she
crushed it under her heel it was that
easy that simple but of course every
time it had come close to her it had
taken another bite out of her mind just
as she took another slash at its form we
opened each other up I filled its body
with holes and it filled my mind with
them there's not much left of me she
curses herself from not having done it
earlier but maybe there was a reason she
can't remember it anymore in any case
the mimics dying bites from her were
particularly damaging the straw that
broke the the camel's back what's left
of Dr Elizabeth Graham is falling apart
she scribbles things down onto the paper
while her mind realizes that she can't
even understand what she's writing
anymore the next document is empty not
every story with the foundation's agents
fighting a monster has a happy ending
picture this you're out driving visiting
the more rural towns of your home
country it's been a long trip hours at a
time or sometimes full days spent on the
open road with brief stops taken only
for gas and snacks every time you hit
the next town you stop for the night
maybe book a day or two at a local hotel
to rest then you're right back out on
the road again it's been a little while
since you left the last town and it's
starting to get late the sun is dipping
behind the Horizon and pretty soon it'll
be night again you don't think it's a
good idea to keep driving all through
the night until tomorrow you need to
sleep the one problem is you don't know
the high my way you're on all that well
and the people at the last Town didn't
mention there being anywhere else to
stay for at least a few more miles but
then you turn on the radio accidentally
tuning in to some kind of locally
produced tourism ad through the airwaves
and the ever-growing evening Darkness
you hear welcome to Chocolate a nice
rural town with a population who just
can't bear to leave located just off the
freeway you'll find our town is filled
with all sorts of colorful folks who
love nothing more than to greet new
faces from the moment you arrive you'll
see firsthand the chocolate Knuckles
love for ah an expression and we even
encourage our younger residents to get
in on the fun and let their Creative
Flair show chocolate once you're here
you just won't be able to leave
chocolate you've never heard of the
place it wasn't on any of the maps when
you planned out your route and it
doesn't even show up on your car's GPS
and what's more the people at the last
town you visited never said anything
about it they said the nearest
neighboring city was much much further
away did they lie why wouldn't they tell
you that this other town was closer you
spot a road sign up ahead pointing
towards the turn for chocolate and
decide to try your chances a good
night's rest and you'll be back on the
road or so you think in any small town
there are bound to be Secrets local
Legends ghost stories even grudges
between families that have lived there
for Generations no matter how friendly
and unassuming a place might seem on the
surface there's always bound to be
something that people just don't talk
about the township of chocolate
otherwise known as
scp-277 is no exception hiding a fair
few secrets of its own although the
locals don't know it they are living
their seemingly ordinary lives under
constant surveillance operatives of the
SCP Foundation have been integrated
among the townsfolk embedded within the
civilian population to monitor some of
the strange happenings going on in this
otherwise normal town so why not take a
walk with us through Main Street down
the Avenues of chocolate as we draw your
attention to some of the Mysteries of
scp-277 the first thing you'll probably
notice as you stroll around town are all
the chalk drawings they're everywhere on
the sidewalks and the outer walls of
buildings scribbled on trash cans and
houses practically every playground in
town has been turned into an urban art
installation for these colorful
children's drawings not at all that
weird at first glance right perhaps it's
a good thing that the town encourages
its kids to express themselves by having
them draw all over the town with chalk
but these images coding the town on
every street corner and Alleyway they
weren't drawn with chalk these
apparitions found throughout the area of
scp-277 might look like harmless art but
not one of them was created in the way
you might expect little Timmy didn't
spend a few minutes on his hands and
knees dragging a lump of chalk over the
concrete oh no the drawings found around
chocolate seem to be projected directly
from the minds of the town's children
all their thoughts their wild and
unfiltered imaginations have somehow
been plastered all over every surface
you can find the foundation calls these
images instances of
scp-277-1 with almost all of them
appearing as figures drawn in white
outlines creepy isn't it like part of a
crime scene luckily some of these
projections take the form of beanstalks
spaceships anything from the imagination
of the child manifesting them an
instance of
scp-277-1 doesn't possess any physical
form or any substantial
three-dimensional body and the size
shape and style and complexity of each
drawing varies all depending on the
child that creates them additionally
it's only children that have the
capacity to produce these images anyone
over the age of pubescence is completely
unable to do so as for how exactly the
children of chocolate create
scp-277-1 instances well most of the
time they aren't even aware that they're
projecting their thoughts into the form
of these anomalous drawings it is an
entirely unconscious and involuntary
process it's hard for the SCP Foundation
to put an exact number on the number of
children in chocolate given the sheer
size of the town and its population so
predicting the exact number of active
instances of
scp-277-1s at any one time is pretty
tricky if not downright unfeasible the
foundation agents embedded among the
townsfolk have been able to confirm that
these drawings or projections are
capable of interacting with fellow
scp-277-1 instances while physical
objects can pass through them without
causing or sustaining any form of damn
damage it is due to this factor that the
children living in scp-277 can often be
seen playing with their chalk
projections and the existence of these
living drawings is viewed as a totally
normal and everyday occurrence by the
adult residents of chocolate in fact you
can ask anyone who grew up living in
scp-277 any lifelong local born and
raised in chocolate and they will tell
you that the living chalk projections of
the town's children have existed as long
as the town itself has according to the
claims of the older residents
scp-277-1 instances have been appearing
in chocolate for years and years dating
all the way back to when scp-277 was
first colonized and the earliest
settlers arrived in the town however the
foundation isn't so sure that these
claims are 100 accurate for one they
can't even find a single record of
scp-277 existing before the 2000s even
those living in neighboring towns refuse
to believe that chocolate is a real
place that exists adding to the mystery
surrounding the town of scp-277 is the
fact that all of its inhabitants also
don't seem to exist or at least have no
official record of their existence
anywhere else according to tests
conducted by the foundation the dental
DNA and fingerprint data of everyone
living in scp-277 don't match any
recorded persons on national population
databases and on top of that none of the
chocolate residents have any memories of
living anywhere else other than the
mysterious Town wherever having traveled
anywhere outside it either no vacations
road trips not even as much as a visit
to relatives in the next town over
naturally before they implanted covert
agents among the locals the SCP
foundation's initial attempt to contain
scp-277 was to evacuate the civilian
population the plan was to remove the
people from the vicinity of the Town
relocate them and then assess the the
local area's anomalous properties what
was it about that specific town that
caused the chalk projections to manifest
why were none of the residents details
anywhere on the national databases and
how could a single one of them never
have once left the confines of chocolate
evacuated an assess that was the goal
but naturally things weren't as simple
in practice multiple failed evacuation
attempts were made with some unforeseen
incidences causing the operation to go
awry in an attempt to combat this the
SCP Foundation tried to vary the
specific details of its evacuation
strategy each time but even then they
couldn't get the people out of the Town
what was perhaps far stranger was that
every time the foundation attempted a
new evacuation the civilians living in
scp-277 denied having any memories of
the earlier failed evacuations there was
so much disbelief in the occurrence of
these prior evacuation attempts that it
caused the foundation to question if
these attempts even took place the only
record of the failed evacuations
existing were in their own files on the
odd occasion that Foundation operatives
were able to get one or two residents of
scp-277 far enough away from the town
they learned it was an exercise in
futility after spending any longer than
a few brief minutes outside the borders
of chocolate a resident would suffer
some sort of violent incident the exact
nature of what would happen to them has
been redacted however we know for a fact
that they weren't killed just by leaving
the town shortly after these evacuated
civilians would be found back within
scp-277 with no memory of ever having
left the town but what was causing all
of these attempted evacuations to fail
what exactly was preventing the
townsfolk from leaving well the answers
to these questions may be found in a
unique instance of
scp-277-1 which are far more actively
hostile versions of the chalk drawings
that were collectively given the
designation
scp-277-1-r these instances first came
about some time before the foundation
started attempting to evacuate chocolate
one of their agents undercover within
the town and monitoring anomalous
activity spotted a seemingly standard
scp-277-1 projection in the shape of a
rabbit it wasn't a drawing that had been
noticed previously so it wasn't present
in any reports coming out of scp-277 but
yet there it was at the local library
none of the town's children admitted to
being responsible for casting this new
projection unusual but not uncommon
after all they are kids think about it
we're sure that as a kid you might have
done something that you didn't fess up
to when a grown-up asked you granted you
probably never cast a psychic projection
onto a library though the foundation
agents within scp-277 knew that the
instances of the chalk drawings could
often be good indicators of the
psychological state of the child child
that manifested them so they aim to keep
an eye out for any further
scp-277-1-r Rapids with a matching
drawing style turns out the agents found
plenty more of these rabbits before long
sightings of
scp-277-1-r instances had tripled in
frequency since that first one appeared
at the library but what was it that made
these projections different from the
regular
scp-277-1 chalk drawings well agent
Davis of the SCP Foundation witnessed a
cluster of these rapid projections
across the street from a diner they were
silently watching people or cars that
pass by at a nearby intersection the
rabbits didn't play like the other
sketches suddenly the agent heard a
scream from a little girl she had been
playing with her own chalk drawings that
took the shape of a pony with wings
agent Davis turned around to see one of
the rabbits attacking the little girl's
sketch practically consuming the drawing
thanks to instances of scp-277-1 being
able to interact each other at the same
time the attacks seemed to cause the
little girl to suffer some form of
seizure all around the rest of the
rabbits were doing the same seeking out
other chalk drawings and devouring them
tearing them apart and causing the
children that created their own
scp-277-1s to suffer the same seizure
ultimately any child who had their
projection attacked by a rabbit collapse
soon after and slipped into a coma with
attempts to awaken them proving
unsuccessful three months later all of
the rabbit drawings seemed to have
vanished with no clue if they had come
from a child or were created from the
town of scp-277 itself the local
civilians gave mixed responses when
asked some claiming to have no memory of
the event that put multiple children in
Tacomas meanwhile other townsfolks
simply stated that this sort of thing
happens in chocolate every few years SCP
Foundation staff noticed that the
residents of scp-277 seemed to smile too
wide when they explained this as if
their town was a fairy tale and that the
massacre was just a part of a happy
ending still if you're thinking of
stopping a chocolate maybe it's safer to
just keep driving for more than a
hundred thousand years Humanity has
buried their dead we commit the bodies
of our deceased to the ground Earth to
Earth ashes to ashes dust to dust in the
hope that one day our dearly departed
might get to enjoy some form of eternal
life but eternal life might be less
appealing than it sounds perhaps there's
a reason that humans bury their dead
maybe it's so that the dead stay buried
and luckily they do at least most of the
time accessible only via a cargo
elevator and not marked on any official
Foundation blueprints beneath the
northwest corner of OverWatch command
lies
scp-5555 this SCP isn't a creature or
carnivorous monster it's not a gateway
to another dimension or an entity with
the power to rewrite the very fabric of
reality itself no
scp-5555 is a mass grave filled with
corpses a pit of Unknown Origin and
indeterminable death each body exhumed
from within
scp-5555 shows various anomalous traits
these bodies can be removed from the
mass grave without any incident but
given the incalcable depth of this vast
corpse-filled pit continued excavation
of scp-5555 would likely only reveal
further bodies and fewer answers as to
how they came to be buried beneath the
foundation's OverWatch command the
bodies were covered during the initial
excavation of scp-5555 vary in their
physical attributes as well as their
causes of death when one can even be
determined one body appears to be a man
whose age and ethnicity are both unclear
as is how he died but his body is
perfectly preserved showing no signs of
decomposition another of the corpses has
its head covered with a burlap sack and
a noose tightened around its neck when
these are removed they reveal an
identical noose and Sack underneath when
those are removed they reveal another
and on and on and on the cause of death
in this instance is at least apparent
strangulation suggesting that the
deceased was intended to suffer before
their death some of the other bodies
removed from the pit include one
belonging to a middle-aged alotic woman
whose entire skeleton is formed of ice
that doesn't melt under increased
temperatures while a different body is a
human male with 80 percent of its organs
surgically replaced with artificial ones
driven by gears and mechanisms that
continue to tick away long after death
an adolescent female with dark blue skin
has two severed hands grasping its
throat while a Caucasian woman was found
with both of her eyes gouged out perhaps
most curious of all is the coffin
crafted from Black Stone that cannot be
opened all attempts to open it have been
resisted by some form of internal Force
keeping the coffin shut while it's
unable to be opened it is believed to
contain a human inside a coffin with a
person inside of it those familiar with
the objects contained by the foundation
may make a connection to
scp-076 Able a humanoid entity also
contained inside a coffin a curious
connection too as you'll come to see
when dealing with
scp-5555 the appearance of many familiar
faces may be more than just vague
connections none of these corpses or
their various anomalous properties
answer any of the pressing questions
about
scp-5555's exact nature and or origin in
fact the bodies found within the grave
only raise new questions about this
seemingly bottomless pit that the
foundation was either built over or
knowingly hides beneath its lowest
depths the truth behind
scp-5555 is shrouded in mystery
unanswered questions piled on top of
each other like the bodies in the mass
grave itself a pile that Stacks all the
way up to the highest levels of the
foundation's own Administration in
actuality the bodies buried in scp-5555
are part of a vast and Insidious game
played by the heads of a number of gois
or groups of Interest as well as the SCP
foundation's very own administrator but
how do the corpses of these anomalous
beings factor into the aforementioned
game and what is the ultimate outcome
examining the file describing as cp55555
albeit with adequate o5 security
clearance answers some of these burning
questions about the mystery at play Dr
Everett Mann the current 05-1 was the
first to uncover the existence of
scp-5555 and the corpses contained
within it man created a series of notes
detailing his findings intended for his
successor in these man claimed that the
administrator won Francis Fritz Williams
the only figure with authority above
that of the o5 council blackballed him
meaning Fritz Williams had voted against
allowing Dr Mann to remain a member of
the SCP Foundation Everett Mann had
believed the administrator to be his
friend so naturally it came as a
surprise when Fritz framed him for an
elaborate plot to eliminate man's fellow
overseer council members based on the
information from his own 05-1
predecessor man believed whoever took up
the role after he was voted out would
have to take up the role of killing
Fritz for the good of the foundation but
what connection between Fritz and a pit
full of anomalous corpses could possibly
want man's urging his successor to
eliminate the foundation's administrator
Dr man's notes to his successor
continued with detailed instructions as
to how they would go about killing Fritz
and that firstly they would require a
lair man himself was holed up in an
isolated Arctic Shack for three decades
after being blackballed by the
administrator before Fritz sent his own
private death squad after the former
overseer man stressed the importance of
having a defensible isolated location
stocked with armed guards and traps for
his successor to lie and wait for Fritz
it was because of the traps man had set
in his Shack that he was able to escape
Fritz's death squad with his life
secondly man urges his new 05-1
successor to always have several escape
plans in place and to be prepared to
leave the lair or indeed any other
location at any time Dr Mann also
suggested telling falsified Escape Plan
to close friends in case Fritz got to
them first or finding an SCP that allows
the new 05-1 to teleport to safety third
man suggests the need for multiple fully
stocked safe houses after all escape
plans are entirely pointless unless
you've got somewhere secure to actually
escape to Everett Mann also suggested
much like his advice with escape plans
to have fake safe houses or SCP
anomalies on hand to get you to the real
ones how does one obtain access to an
SCP according to man placing moles or
blackmailing Personnel within every
Foundation facility is one way as doing
so granted him access to scp-268 a hat
that makes its wear practically
invisible which came in handy during his
Escape of course installing your own
trusted moles is a potentially tricky
feat to accomplish given that Fritz has
the entire foundation and many other
groups of interest in his thrall but if
anyone has has the power to do so and by
extension the power to bring Fritz down
it would be another overseer of course
man's plot to eliminate Fritz and highly
detailed words of warning to his
successor do little to explain the
pitfull of anomalous corpses contained
within the file for scp-5555 is an email
to the foundation's administrator from
the CEO of wondertainment an anomalous
toy manufacturer and one of a number of
groups of interest to the foundation in
it the CEO congratulates Fritz on an
excellent win and asks for a copy of an
unknown file as well as mentioning the
leaders of other groups of Interest such
as the Church of the broken God
according to the email this unidentified
file was to be sent physically as
opposed to electronically giving Dr Mann
his next lead in uncovering The Mystery
of
scp-5555 man traveled to the
headquarters of wondertainment
Wonderworld to retrieve the file using
his special have to avoid detection
seems like an easy enough task except
Wonder World is a pocket Dimension that
slowly transforms human beings into
something else time working against him
man hastily made his way to Wonder Tower
and attempted to recover the file that
would maybe give him all the answers to
this bizarre Twisted mystery
unfortunately wondertainment CEO Dr
Holly wondertainment got to him first
confronted by Dr wondertainment Everett
Mann demanded to know who was involved
in the scheme besides her and the
administrator he posited that the o5
council might be somehow involved but Dr
wondertainment claimed that the game
being played was above and beyond their
Little Numbers Club Holly proceeded to
point a large acid-filled Super Soaker
at man and ordered him down onto his
knees when they asked what purpose of
the mass grave
scp-5555 was following a fight and the
apparent death of Dr wondertainment man
escaped Wonderworld with the file
containing an updated version of the
scp-5555 description and containment
procedures the key points featured in
this scp-5555 document are mentions of
sealing the mass grave with concrete
after completing the turnover and
re-establishing the facade it also
mentions that any already cataloged SCP
entering the pit will die with its
personality attributes and any anomalous
qualities being passed on to a new
entity which will appear close to the
location of the initial scp's Discovery
so the pit can not only kill any SCP
that enters it but can also instantly
recreate them with slight differences
and reposition them does this mean the
bodies in scp-555 are those of former
scps to answer that we'll have to take
another look at the corpses let's take a
look at some of these bodies and try to
make some connection
we already discussed the similarities
between the coffin and scp-076 able The
Entity who also rests inside a large
black coffin next we have a corpse
dressed in yellow with a burlap sack
covering its head tightened in place
with a noose and removing it causes
another sack and another noose to appear
under it if you ask us that sounds a lot
like
scp-701 the hanged King's tragedy which
revolves around a play that Heralds the
arrival of a mysterious entity that
calls itself the hanged King a being
with connections to the
extra-dimensional realm of alagada the
hanged King entity and scp-701 reveals
in decadence and Chaos so maybe it's
better for it to be thrown into
scp-5555 next we have a corpse that's
been altered with mechanical gears that
certainly sounds familiar too
scp-217 is a virus that turns the body
into to A Clockwork being replacing
organs and tissue with the appearance of
gears and metal Foundation researchers
even noticed the similarity between the
body and the appearance of a corpse
fully transformed by a cp217 but there's
also the connection to Dr Charles gears
the famed researcher who acts as cold as
ice and frequently researches anomalies
with connections to the mechanite
religion and the Church of the broken
God it's been long rumored that gears's
body is also altered taking on the
appearance of clockwork there's no
telling what this connection means but
it's definitely something to think about
next in our retrospective we have a
white woman whose eyes were gouged out
while this doesn't exactly narrow
anything down The Corpse's secondary
anomalous properties certainly do
photographs of the body show a pair of
blue eyes that when viewed through video
follow the camera a girl and a camera
that sounds a lot like scp-105 5. the
photographer formerly known as Iris
Thompson who can manipulate the images
in the photographs she takes on her
camera iris is typically one of the
friendlier more approachable anomalies
housed by the foundation and seeing her
like this is heartbreaking so if the
corpses in the pit are former scps
themselves and existing objects are
reincarnated and modified after being
placed there how many times has this
happened over the years hidden files
display text results involving numerous
ultra-famous anomalies including
SCP-173 which reappeared in an art
exhibit before it was contained again
but Foundation researchers were shocked
to find that this time the statue was
made of concrete giving it the
appearance we all know today another
test example involved scp-049 the plague
doctor who was lured into the pit using
a vial of liquid that he was convinced
contained a vital component to his
medical Mission SC
p049 reappeared in France this time
wearing the familiar plague doctor mask
over his apparent previous attire a gas
mask there had been mention of some sort
of game being played by the foundation
administrator and the heads of various
groups of interests involving a number
of anomalies and the killing and
Recreation of different scps many
turning into those that exist within the
SCP archive after Dr Everett Mann's
encounter with Dr Holly wondertainment
an email to Fritz from the head of the
global occult Coalition congratulated
the administrator for an exciting
addition to the game in the form of Dr
Mann tracking the gois leaders some such
as the leader of the Church of the
broken God contacted Fritz to express
their displeasure at including the risk
of being murdered by man they claim that
introducing such a rogue element to the
game after Fritz had already won felt
like an indulgent Victory lap in
addition one reported that Hollywood
entertainment had proclaimed dying to be
unpleasant when she had woken up after
man had seemingly killed her in trying
to uncover the truth about this Sinister
game man had found himself an unwilling
participant it appeared that the
administrator and the GOI leaders were
Immortal and while they could be
temporarily killed like Dr
wondertainment it wasn't exactly an
enjoyable experience some GOI leaders
even theorized that Fritz introduced man
to their game as a way of eliminating
them or their organizations however man
had no desire to kill any of them apart
from Fritz himself the leader of the
entire game in his notes man urges his
05-1 successor to share the scp-555 file
with the other members of the o5 council
to spread awareness of the danger that
Fritz his various conspirators and their
game poses traveling to England man
attempted to obtain Fritz's location
from Robert bomero high priest of the
Church of of the broken God however he
found himself trapped by bomero and
Hermann Fuller head of another group of
Interest the anomalous circus Fuller
knew that man had worked alongside Fritz
for years and could prove useful for the
next round of the game while Romero told
him to Simply kill Dr Mann stating he
wasn't worth dying again however Fritz
appeared shortly after to take man into
custody threatening to kill his
associates but marrow and Fuller if they
didn't release man while Romero appeared
more afraid of the dying process Fuller
refused to relent resulting in an
exchange of gunfire Fritz dragged the
injured man away patched up his wounds
and left him in a safe house with clean
clothes bathroom facilities and a note
explaining what had happened Fritz's
node told man that he'd left him a plane
ticket to Toronto encouraging him to
travel there and to take out the critic
head of are we cool yet one of Fritz's
fellow conspiracy orders the
administrator also left another updated
version of the scp-5555 file this time
detailing not scps that had been
replaced but members of foundation staff
it also stated that 05-2 205-13 were all
dead at Fritz's hand leaving only Dr
Mann 05-1 as Fritz felt like they'd
bonded reassuring the other leaders that
he wasn't acting against them Fritz
explained through emails that he had
shaped man into the perfect element for
their game man departed for Toronto
assaulting the critic in an effort to
gain more information while also
simultaneously carrying out Fritz's
wishes Dr Everett Mann for his part
continued to carry out Fritz's Dirty
Work tracking the various GOI leaders
and replaced Foundation staff determined
to topple Fritz and his game once and
for all come the start of the new game
Fritz and all his associates had
switched roles with each other the
administrator of the foundation took on
the role of Dr wondertainment Dr
wondertainment became the prophet of
meccane a representative of the Church
of the broken God the role of the global
occult coalition's D.C alfene became
Jude kairod a member of the mischievous
Gamers against weed group of Interest
this new iteration of the game also
assigned Dr Mann the role of nobody his
win conditions for the game were to kill
all the others having himself been made
one of them an immortal by Fritz
assembling his notes for the future 05
Council man set out on this hunt for
Fritz carrying with him a Relentless
Grudge and signing off with a single
item on a to-do list kill Fritz the
story of scp-5555 and the ongoing game
that it relates to perhaps explains why
we bury our dad sometimes uncovering
them can reveal secrets that should
never see the light of day some secrets
much like the dead are best left buried
it was dark when you arrived at the
office rain hammered down on the window
pane cold as death your therapist didn't
expect a friend to call from you in the
middle of the night but he learned to
take such surprises as they came you
called and drove over the second you had
the dream that terrible terrible dream
he was sitting at his desk when you
entered the room he gestured to the
couch encouraging you to take a seat and
make yourself comfortable your heart was
beating so hard you were worried it
might break your ribs every time you
blinked you were getting flashes of the
faces those vacant grinning faces with
white eyes and mouths wrenched open
Hanging slack you hope to whatever God
or Gods you believed in to never see
those images outside of a dream that's
been troubling you this time he asked I
must admit I'm getting a little worried
about
seemed so frantic over the phone you
tried your best to settle your breathing
for long enough to speak at which point
you said the words you were hoping you'd
never have to say again I had a dream of
how cracklewood Park you could almost
hear the Sigh your therapist was
desperately trying to conceal from you
he'd been making so much progress
processing and working to move beyond
that mysterious trauma but then the
dreams had come back just as forceful
and terrifying as they ever were your
therapist asked you to recount it just
like he did so many times before but of
course it's always the same in the dream
you were a child probably about six or
seven walking down a long cobbled path
surrounded on all sides by these trees
that looked like Eerie amusement park
animatronics they had these big rubbery
faces stretched into Eerie Smiles like
something off the cover of an old
children's book the craggle trees you
somehow knew deep down in your heart
that this was what the trees were called
this was after all cracklewood Park
those words in Whimsical cursive letters
were written on an aging sign somewhere
deep in your mind you could remember it
as clearly as your own mother's face and
you weren't alone here in cracklewood
park there were other children wandering
down that cobbled road like a lost scene
from The Wizard of Oz the trees grinned
and gyrated and sang up against a
painted Forest background wait was it
painted or did it just seem somehow
unreal the memories were getting hazy
here the same goes for the faces of the
other children and were smudged out
forgotten why were you here why were any
of you here and where were your parents
in all this but those thoughts were
blotted out by the singing of those
awful trees you couldn't remember the
words but the music was so clear The
Haunting notes of a calliope organ like
a collapsing memory of a day at the
circus you and the other children were
all walking in the same direction as
though in a trance what were you walking
towards the calliope only got louder
with every step a boy with a smudged out
face to the left of you trying to speak
but his words were muffled you couldn't
hear anything over the music and the
terrible garbled singing of all the
animatronic trees then there were
glowing lights and colors as you
approach the end of the road something
big moving in time to the music a grand
old Carousel slowly grinding to a halt
to let on the next wave of children you
and the others just stood there and
watched it moments later half of the
crowd of assembled children the boy
standing next to you included began to
step onto the carousel the light got
brighter and the singing got louder by
the time you reached the end of
recounting your dream to your therapist
you realize that your cheeks were wet
with tears you told him you'd do
anything to get the dreams to stop
anything your therapist just nodded and
made node in this journal I'll get in
touch with someone who specializes in
this kind of scene he said try to get
some rest in the meantime it can be
detrimental to obsess about this kind of
thing but how could you not obsess the
second you got home you did what you
always did after having another
cracklewood Park dream you went straight
to the forums after all the most
frightening thing about the kraglewood
dream was the fact that you weren't the
only one having it a number of people
had congregated on a niche online
paranormal Forum to discuss their eerily
similar experiences dreams filled with
singing uncanny trees have forgotten
children and the hazy horrors of
craglewood park each member of The Forum
alerted the others whenever they had the
dream again and through any new
information into the pot they came from
all over the world different ages
backgrounds and countries making it
impossible that they'd all actually
visited a place like cracklewood park at
some point in their past and really the
only thing they had in common other than
the dream itself was the fact that they
were all only children while in them
none of them could explain the dream
perhaps with almost 8 billion people on
Earth it could be a coincidence that
this handful would have these peculiar
dreams perhaps that's all it was strange
dreams a few days later a stranger
arrived at your door telling you that
they were referred to you by your
therapist they heard about the dreams
about cracklewood Park in fact they
dealt with similar cases in the past and
if you'd be willing to answer a few
questions they may even have a viable
treatment for the strange dreams that
have been assailing you for years now
what could go wrong anything that could
stop you from seeing those awful tree
faces would be good you relayed
everything that you'd previously told
your therapist every detail of the dream
the rough number of times had reoccurred
and even the support group for the other
sufferers that you frequented online
after you answered all the strangers
questions they told you that in order to
seek treatment for your strange dreams
you would only need to show up at a
nearby building and tell them who you
are they told you that this is a highly
confidential and experimental procedure
so it would need to be kept secret you
sign a non-disclosure agreement and
happily submit to all their conditions
you'll do anything to stop dreaming
about cracklewood Park even agree to
what you don't know is amnestic
treatment from the SCP Foundation we're
testing to see if erasing memories can
suppress the craglewood park dreams you
are among the first group of guinea pigs
for that experiment but hey if it works
it works right and for a few weeks it
did you submitted yourself to regular
amnestic treatment sessions at a local
Foundation front business disguised as a
legitimate Medical Center you were
skeptical at first you'd tried every
therapy and over-the-counter sleeping
pill you could get your hands on you
tried meditation regression hypnosis
positive subliminals nothing had
vanished Down The Haunting dreams of
cracklewood Park those trees those faces
those awful tinny songs but to your
immense relief this new course of
treatment seemed to hold strong while
taking the medication given to you by
the foundation you got your best nights
of sleep in years A Whole New World of
comfort and peace but then came a
problem there were supply issues you'd
need to take a few weeks off the course
and just as soon as you stop taking the
regular course of medications the second
your head hit the pillow and you drifted
off to sleep you were right back in
cragglewood park it wasn't fair it just
wasn't fair perhaps the nightmares would
go on forever you'd spend every evening
with those other faceless children
always wondering who were they what
happened to them little did you know
there were no supply issues the
foundation just wanted to test the
viability of amnestic treatment as a
long-term solution to the kraglewood
park dreams or as they dubbed them
scp-2571 turns out the amnestics were
only effective when the subjects of
scp-2571 were actively taking them given
the foundation tests have estimated
around .05 percent of the world's
population are affected by
scp-2571 with that number possibly On
The Rise by unknown means consistent
amnestic treatment for all affected was
deemed to not be a viable solution but
if it's any consolation to you you're
not suffering alone the SCP Foundation
has an online bot known as IO Mandela
trawling the internet for any
discussions relevant to
scp-2571 they also have a designated
task force mtf-57 also known as the
laughing stock to investigate and follow
up on cases related to the cine Mr
kraglewood Park the foundation has
conducted thousands of interviews
related to the subject but only three
are appended to the file containing
between them some Revelations on
cracklewood Park that reveal it's
actually far far worse than a childish
bad dream Dr Raynor the research team
leader for
scp-2571 conducted the first of the
three pertinent interviews about
scp-2571 investigating the experience of
one Rupert Duca Su in many ways Rupert's
cracklewood Park dreams were truly
textbook Ventures into this nightmare of
an amusement park he described venturing
through the park saying I enter this
theme park it's like Disneyland but
smaller there's no rides just this long
Winding Road through the woods
everything's bright and colorful like a
cartoon and then there's these trees all
around me but they've all got faces and
they're singing they've got these Dopey
cheerful looks like in one of those
old-time cartoons right and they just
sing and laugh and say thing like all
the other accounts who reported
approaching a carousel with the other
children half of the children got onto
the Carousel and he and the others began
to leave at this point Rupert became
visibly distressed while recounting the
tail and said just as I'm getting ready
to leave I see something a tiny tree
sprouting up near my foot it looks up at
me it's smiling smiling with that big
Dopey happy grin when I see it that's
when I start screaming that's when I
wake up when Dr Raynor asked Rupert why
he started screaming Rupert replied that
the tree had his face the interview
concluded next Dr Raynor spoke to Jenny
yearling another victim of
scp-2571 Dr Raynor shifted his line of
questioning to the Carousel specifically
Miss yearling insisted that she never
stepped onto the carousel herself some
who did were smiling others were crying
they hugged some of the children that
chose to stay behind before they got on
the more she described what happened the
more distressed Miss yearling seemed to
become she eventually broke down into
mortified sobs from the recollection
when Dr Rainier asked what was wrong
Miss yearling said one of the kids one
of the kids that got on why why did he
hug me I didn't I don't even know who he
was before breaking down into horribly
desperate choked sobbing the final
interview and what it led to was the
most eventful and disturbing of all why
because this interview conducted by Dr
Rainier with Randolph Blair was the
first time that a physical item in a
subject's home proved that
scp-2571 may be much more than just a
malicious dream an old VHS videotape was
found in Mr Blair's attic with the word
craglewood scrawled across the top when
the foundation made Blair watch the tape
and asked him if he recognized any of
the images in it he told them that he
only recognized them from nightmares he
theorized that perhaps he'd been shown
the tape as a child and it had
traumatized him the foundation didn't
think that that was the case Dr Rainier
pressed on and asked him about a few
strange details like the resemblance
between himself and one of the two
children in the video and the strangely
vacant front-facing bedroom in his
childhood home at this point Dr Rainier
realized that Mr Blair wouldn't be
forthcoming for much longer he decided
to use that little time he had left to
ask Mr Blair one more question have you
always been an only child that question
would forever go unanswered but Dr
Rainier could now take an educated guess
the foundation watched and analyzed the
tape finding it eerily similar to so
many of the dreams that came before a
young Randolph Blair and another young
child that the foundation believed to be
his brother wandered through craglewood
park with the others until they finally
reached the carousel there Randolph said
a tearful goodbye as his brother stepped
up onto the carousel knowing somehow
that he would never be seen again and as
Randolph tried to leave in a panic
moments later her he was cornered by
another horrifying craggle tree this
time with his brother's face singing in
his voice because cracklewood Park isn't
a terrifying Dream It's a terrifying
memory the ocean is a terrifying Place
we've all heard the statistics more than
80 percent of the ocean remains
unexplored that's most of the water
covering the globe completely unmapped
and unobserved by science it's a scary
thought to dwell on realizing that
there's more water than land on Earth
and the sheer expanse of that water is
so large that we've been unable to fully
explore all of it just think there are
places in the ocean that have never been
seen by a human who knows what's down
there if there was ever a
personification of fear of the unknown
the ocean could definitely be it ancient
shipwrecks sunk to the ocean floor
unknown sea creatures hiding away from
humanity and the general isolation of
the suffocate getting dark blue the
ocean swallows its victims with all of
these images that come to mind when
thinking about the vast and mysterious
deaths of the sea and no one is more
familiar with nautical Mysteries than
the SCP Foundation today we'll be taking
a look at
scp-5007 the Bass Strait a wave of
oceanic anomalies fit to make any
seasoned sailor shiver and fear the Bass
Strait is an area of ocean dividing
Tasmania and the Australian Mainland
it's also the location of an unusually
high amount of disappearances Sailors
disappearing from their ships fishermen
leaving in the night and never coming
back even civilians disappearing from
the shores that connect to the strait
the foundation was aware of these
disappearances since 1858 but were only
able to craft theories about what was
causing them was it an anomalous group
of Interest hostile aerial entities
patrolling the skies above the strait
phenomenon associated with unidentified
flying objects what about subterranean
anomalies weather patterns or time
dilation for nearly a century the
foundation was unable to determine the
cause of the high number of
disappearances in the Bass Strait and
then the phenomenon suddenly revealed
itself in 1980 on a beach connected to
the strait agent taverner an operative
of the SCP Foundation was vacationing
with his wife Mary and his three young
children the taverner family was simply
enjoying their day when they saw what
looked like balloons in the sky they
were approaching quickly and naturally
the family moved closer what happened
next was a whirlwind and those balloons
the family were so interested in Lifted
them up from the ground and carried them
away agent taverner tried to fight back
but there was nothing he could do except
report to the foundation what had
occurred and the organization responded
in full force the foundation's research
discovered that reports of UFOs and
lights in the sky had coincided with
many disappearances in the strait and
that this this was a pattern the search
for the four lost taverner family
members had become a large-scale
investigation into unexplained
disappearances along the Bass Strait and
within three weeks it was determined
that these patterns were consistent
across the entirety of The Straits
coastal regions some witnesses were
interviewed but the vast majority of
these abduction cases had no Witnesses
whatsoever of the minimal reports filed
the foundation was told that there were
lights in the sky and that appearance of
unidentified flying objects described as
having the appearances of balloons one
such witness interviewed was a man by
the name of Alan Stewart a witness who
was present during The Disappearance of
former Australian prime minister Harold
Holt whose disappearance the foundation
believed may have had a connection to
the Bass Strait anomalies during the
interview Stewart claimed that Holt and
his family while voyaging on their yacht
decided to leave the boat and go for a
swim Holt turned to Stewart and asked
him if he could see the balloons around
the cliff Stewart had no idea what Holt
was talking about but Holt was insistent
on seeing them he swam deeper out into
the ocean saying that they weren't
normal balloons and that there was
someone inside of them Stuart and halt's
family called out for him to come to
shore but he wouldn't listen Stewart
tried to rationalize what he saw next
maybe it was the current sweeping halt
away but he couldn't lie to the
foundation interviewer Stewart saw Holt
go further and further out into the
water and suddenly the Prime Minister
turned around he began swimming in the
opposite direction and he was screaming
suddenly Holt was lifted from the sea
and pulled into the air by something
emerging from the clouds the foundation
thanks Steward for the interview and
continued their investigation two years
later in 1982 Emergency Services
received a large number of calls
pertaining to UFO sightings off the
coast of Norman Bay Victoria the
foundation was quick to respond alerting
task forces and local sites to prepare
for an investigation upon arriving to
the scene they confirmed the existence
of multiple entities that would later be
documented as
scp-5007 they evacuated civilians from
the area and successfully managed to
capture the creature which was later
transported to site-40 for containment
it was a sight to Behold The Entity now
designated
scp-5007-s-1 was a cluster of human
bodies fused between a grouping of black
tentacles of varying length each
tentacle was fused to the skin it
touched directly the stomachs of the
corpses were grossly swollen and
distorted to massive sizes to hold large
quantities of gases inside the buoyancy
of which The Entity used to achieve a
passive flight across the entity's
surface were clusters of eyes and
bioluminescent glowing organs many of
the humanoid components of the corpses
appear to have been removed and
misplaced across various parts of the
entity's body what's more is that the
foundation discovered that human
portions of scp-5007 appeared somewhat
cognizant and aware of their situation
their vocalizations were incoherent and
barely understandable consisting of
gasping and whimpering but the corpses
were observed to implore other
individuals to approach them when
encountered
scp-5007's behavior during abduction
scenarios was documented during the
initial containment event and due to the
foundation's painstaking research a
pattern was established between all
scp-5007 encounters first the victim
would be alone or otherwise vulnerable
in a coastal location
scp-5007 haven't shown a preference for
weather be they clear or hostile Skies
but they have localized all their
activity to the Bass Strait in small
coastal towns beaches or boats
scp-5007 will then move towards the
shore stalking the victim before
lowering its tentacles and appendages to
grab the individual snatching them into
the sky an scp-5007 instance can even
abduct multiple people at once one event
observed had eight men from the decks of
a commercial fishing boat taken into the
sky in under 15 seconds once captured
scp-5007 instances will Dart across the
water at a high speed and take their
victims to an unknown location
discovering where scp-5007 took their
victims became a top priority for the
foundation after extensive witness
interviews and compiling a database of
likely victims they determined that
there must be at least 16 instances of
scp-5007 unaccounted for personnel kept
a close watch on the coastlines and
Waters of the Bass Strait and equipped
various Marine task forces with research
vessels capable of tracking any
instances if they encounter them in 1985
the foundation's research efforts paid
off and several survey teams operating
in the area reported a sighting of an
extremely large
scp-5007 instance heading towards a
coastal town a mobile task force was
sent to track the entity the team
observed The Entity from afar as it
stocked a private fishing boat even from
the distance Foundation Personnel
recognized the likenesses of several
missing persons as faces of the corpses
of scp-5007 the task force Captain had
to remind his team to keep it together
claiming that they were not people but
just parts of the specimen but everyone
secretly knew the truth the fishing
vessel was a private one occupied by a
small family The Entity slowly
approached and quickly pulled a woman
into the air the family panicked and
quickly tried to reach cover for safety
running into the Ship's Cabin The Entity
ran its tentacles along the boat until
it pulled the door open snatching
another two victims the task force was
unable to help them as their mission was
to track the instance to its origin
point it was a horror to watch the task
force implanted a tracking Beacon onto
the entity and quietly followed it out
to sea over the next four hours they
then discovered a large gray Reef with
several shipwrecks dotted across 13
scp-5007 instances floated over the area
some holding on to the land Reef with
their tentacles The Entity dropped the
abductees from the fishing boat who were
coerced by the entities into diving into
a massive pool of water located in the
center of the reef one by one each
abductee was pulled below the surface by
something lurking in the pool all while
the scp-5007 instances watched disgusted
the task force reported what they
observed to the main site and the reef
would be designated as
scp-5007-a the foundation's analysis of
the reef led to the discovery that The
Rock covering it seeped iron oxide from
an unknown source and the Rocks achieved
growth at an anomalously fast rate often
as little as 40 minutes all of the
wrecked ships and aircraft that washed
across the shore of the reef were
covered with a dark stone The Reef was
teeming with anomalous marine life
including
scp-5007 a red algae that fed upon the
freshly grown Rock Marine worms capable
of levitation spiders that lived in silk
Retreats underneath the water line small
fish and giant organisms resembling
large clumps of kelp which the
foundation had previously documented as
scp-4159 in a separate investigation
scp-5007 often rested their tentacles on
the outcroppings of the reef while
inactive but what caught the
foundation's attention the most was the
giant pit located in the reef center
unmanned exploration drones found that
it had a depth of at least four thousand
meters and water samples taken from the
pits revealed large quantities of human
DNA prehistoric bacteria and unknown
compounds that possess significant life
preserving qualities when a being was
submerged in the compound they were able
to survive heavy injuries even when
fully surrounded by the liquid and
unable to breathe the foundation's
exploration of one of these shipwrecks
LED them to a journal most of it was
illegible due to water damage but one
passage survived local located in the
back of the book it detailed the
experience of an unknown crew member of
the ship caught in a storm it reads
Mosby spied land ahead and the boys said
that their giant balloons hanging over
the island we are all feared but there
is not we can do but Beach ourselves and
help for rescue should I be killed in
the crash I want my mates to give this
journal to my Mary might know I spent my
last thinking only of her the interior
of the ship contained human remains
inside but there were less skeletons
than the foundation would expect for a
ship of its size the location of the
rest of the bodies was unknown another
event related to scp-5007 the foundation
documented involved Frederick valentic a
pilot engaged in a training flight over
the Bass Strait in 1978. valentic's
disappearance was marked by his latest
communication with air traffic control
when he mistook an scp-5007 instance for
an unidentified aircraft it seems like
it's stationary what I'm doing right now
is orbiting and the thing is just
orbiting on top of me also it's got a
green light and sort of metallic like
it's all shiny on the outside shortly
after this valentech's transmission was
interrupted by what was described as
metallic scraping sounds believed to be
the scp-5007 instance attacking the
aircraft and jamming its propellers with
its mass after crashing into the reef it
was believed that valentic and his
aircraft were pulled beneath the surface
of the pit just as the abductees had
been prior the foundation decided to
construct a provisional secure research
facility on the reef they named it site
40-r and documented all returns and
departures of scp-5007 they also set up
a series of containment procedures that
resulted in an scp-5007 returning with
its victims 83 percent less often than
before the site's construction but this
was short-lived in 2008 the site logged
over 36 instances returning to the reef
with only two not having any fresh
abductees the instance's origins were
unknown and it was as if they appeared
out of thin air no other monitoring post
had documented their appearance or even
spotted them before they arrived at The
Reef it was years later in 2017 that the
foundation eventually was able to
successfully explore what was deep
inside the pit at the center of the reef
they already knew that there was a large
entity lurking beneath as evidenced by
what happened to the victims of scp-5007
that were later deposited inside the
pool all previous attempts to explore
the pool were met with failure as the
water pressure of the Pit's depths
caused all craft to collapse due to Hull
damage this time however they managed to
construct a high-tech submarine labeled
the scps Nautilus which was capable of
diving a maximum of 13 500 meters
underwater they decided that a d-class
Personnel would be trained to man The
submersible and carry out the
exploration the mission was simple the
Nautilus was to dive to the bottom of
the pit and to describe the depth
readings cameras and microphones were
equipped to the vessel due to the depth
remote viewing of the footage was
impossible instead the foundation had to
physically recollect the vessel in order
to view the footage upon recovery some
of the footage suffered data corruption
but what was there shook those who
viewed it to their core the footage
showed the d-class's experience going
deeper inside the pit at first it seemed
ordinary the trench had a number of
Rocky outcroppings dotted with black
yellow Vines growing along the walls
also present were various marine life
forms such as the spiders or the fish
going deeper the sub-observed an
scp-5007 instance clinging to an
outcropping several tendrils emerging
from the Pit's depths were wrapped
around the instance and holding on to
the entity as if it were feeding from it
another 16
scp-5007 instances were seen resting
along the walls each clinging to the
outcropping as the sub went deeper the
d-class remarked that there were dozens
of plane and shipwrecks but also well
over 100
scp-5007 entities most of them were held
there by the black tendrils the d-class
as the sub went even deeper began
noticing human remains no short amount
of them either deep into the pit there
was a large mass of human remains
covering the entirety of the pit bodies
crushed and drained of blood but still
possessing intact eyes each individual
was still alive kept preserved by the
life-sustaining compounds found within
the water the body stared at the sub and
moved attempting to grab onto the
vehicle the d-class swore they were
trying to say something mouthing words
to the camera of the sub as the sub
passed through the mass of bodies it
emerged into a completely dark black
clearing at the bottom of the pit for a
second the d-class thought he was safe
but then a large black tentacle rapidly
emerged from below and grabbed onto the
Nautilus dragging it even further Into
the Depths the d-class screamed and
panicked but there was nothing he could
do the tentacle possessed a large
cluster of eyes mouths and human heads
seemingly grafted onto its mass and then
there was another tentacle and then
another the Nautilus was pulled to the
bottom of the pool the d-class's screams
were still heard even as the picture cut
out sometimes graphic body altering
images of the tentacles features were
visible on the screen but most of the
footage was indecipherable after minutes
of distorted corrupted footage the
Nautilus was seen again rapidly
ascending to the surface somehow it had
managed to escape the entity at the
bottom of the pit upon recovery of The
Craft it was found that the Nautilus was
covered in a thick organic coating
similar to a black slime mold but with
dozens of eyes growing from it the
d-class inside showed severe
psychological damage and attempted to
harm Foundation Personnel they were
terminated shortly after due to being a
danger to those around them following
review of the footage the Nautilus was
to be dismantled and incinerated along
with the remains of the decline
a reinforced containment seal was fitted
over the pit with the intention of
keeping whatever was down there isolated
from the surface but this was
short-lived after the containment seal
was fitted site 40 underwent a massive
Communications blackout every device on
site received an email containing a
single image of a large eye taken from a
security camera the text beneath it
simply read found you some Personnel who
viewed the email underwent anomalous
changes growing new physical features
such as eyes and other various growths
across their body the entirety of site
40-r went offline and the foundation
could not establish contact in an
emergency effort to do so mobile task
force gamma-6 deep feeders was sent to
investigate the task Force's assault on
site-40-r was a daring effort as the
majority of the site was completely
overtaken by tentacles growths and
anomalous alterations while numerous
altered Personnel were lost due to the
mission it was ultimately a success some
altered Personnel were able to be saved
through extensive surgery to remove
their anomalous growths and after
everything was said and done the site
was repaired and reconstructed without
incident following the site's repair
there has been little activity from The
Entity within the pit but the foundation
continued to keep an eye on the creature
and the ecosystem of the anomalous
marine life that live on the Bass Strait
never knowing what their next move might
be and always keeping in mind the risk
that comes with dealing with these
poorly understood entities from the
Garden of Eden to the top corner of your
English teacher's desk apples have
played an equal role in history's most
remarkable days and also its most
mundane the sounds of teeth snapping
through the skin sinking into flesh and
spitting out seeds echo through space
forever and onward and for most of our
Earthly hours consumed by appetite it
has been documented to be a lopsided
relationship between these two things
man and apple men getting the sweet
taste abundant nutrients Apple's getting
nothing but pain and stomach acids but
this story is not found in our history
buried in the lawful patterns of
predator and prey we stumble upon in
irregularity an inversion an instance of
Apple's biting back
scp-4608 also known as apple seed was a
60-acre apple orchard containing over 22
000 trees located just on the outskirts
of Milan Indiana a town so small it
strains your eyes as you squint to find
it with a microscope hovering just over
a map and to see what was actually
happening within the Curious fringes of
society took even greater exploration
not just of the eyes but also of the
mind because what would eventually be
seen would not so easily be comprehended
physical senses are just the surface and
we need to go deeper Our Story begins
with a great Logging Company looking to
take ownership of the most fertile land
they could find in the Great Lakes
region ideally land that overproduces
Conifer growth so that the return on
their investment would be plentiful and
Perpetual these lumberjacked men knew
what they wanted beneath their red
flannel shirts and muddy boots was a
deep intelligence and understanding of
nature their process of assessing the
land's value was meticulously calculated
they knew the soil both by the
experience of their calloused hands and
the literature of their study they
tracked various bird species migration
patterns in the area to assess what kind
of seeds they'd be carrying and
contributing to soil by way of their
stool they understood the local laws
relating to clear cutting and
conservation and how both would affect
their profit margins this is all to say
it wasn't just a speculative purchase
this was planned through and through and
dwelled on and yet even then with
scrupulous eyes and careful crew they
missed the warning signs
scp-4608 checked all their boxes and
then some what could go wrong and so
they acquired the land unwittingly
purchasing the Peril that came with it
on the first day of owning the property
one crew member noticed the branches did
not Sway in the same direction as the
wind blew he noticed the leaves didn't
float down in agreement with their
feathery weight but rather crashed to
the soil like two-dimensional anvils and
grand pianos The Roots were not ones you
simply trip over instead it seemed as if
they stuck their leg out to trip you
when Birds perched themselves up high
and sang their songs their Cadence
carried all the eeriness of an SOS with
all this said he was happy to have
acquired the land and having already
picked up and moved his family from the
west coast to now live and work out in
Milan Indiana he decided it was best to
look past his concerns after all it was
the first day on the new site and
excitement was in the air but with it
also an amorphous anxious energy during
the first logging Expedition within
scp-4608 this same member crew hiked the
grounds to better familiarize himself
with the environment he'd be working on
hoping that if he managed the land
properly and extracted the lumber as
efficiently as his late father did he
would be able to help build the business
and give his children the life he always
promised them he brought with him his
notepad and took detailed records of his
surroundings he figured to achieve his
goals and sustain long-term yields he'd
have to cooperate with his environment
but he never questioned if his
environment wanted to cooperate with him
would this question have changed the
course of action or is brooding on the
preference of plants and empty gesture
best left for hippies at Woodstock
either way the orchard let it be known
how it felt about a collaboration when
hours later the man was found dead it
was first believed by his co-workers to
be a result of a safety equipment
malfunction maybe it was a simple matter
of thinking the skitter was in part when
it was really in neutral maybe the
knuckle boom loader went on the fritz
how it does when the humidity ramps up
maybe Machinery really to blame in which
case you call it a fluke and ask no more
after all there's only so many questions
you can ask a robot but initial belief
is a Fickle thing and it wasn't long
until first impressions were called into
question by the courts of critical
thinking the questions of the crew
however only rang briefly because
shortly after the first death fell a
sequence of others in a matter of days
all the remaining crew members were
declared dead or missing a word reserved
for search parties still clinging to
Hope a hot potato they would have been
wise to abandon for while it was hoped
that brought these search parties
together it was hope that sent them off
never to be seen again the foundation
was then alerted to the occurrences
surrounding
scp-4608 by police reports accompanied
by a photograph a photograph of an
scp-4608-1 an organism consisting of
unidentified plant-like muscular
structures and a periderm resembling
those found on common Hardwoods from the
photograph alone it was clear that this
three meter tall organism was capable of
committing the violence recently endured
forceful in its demeanor aggressive in
its presence and territorial in its
perception the photograph of
scp-4608-1 led to an even bigger
question is this plant-like creature
grown by nature or sown by man after
extensive research by the foundation
records were retrieved that indicate the
entirety of the 60-acre land was sown
into Life by John Chapman in 1826.
Chapman was the type of man you could
mistake for a scarecrow both for reasons
of preferred Garb and Body Language he
was treated as such too his personal
space was respected maybe too much he
spent his life alone only accompanied
and comforted by the things he planted
he maintained these Acres all by himself
until his eventual death in 1845 and
it's then that it's believed
scp-4608 became unstable reassigning its
objective from Comfort to chaos when the
newspaper came out the next Sunday John
Chapman's obituary painted him as a
priest of the Allen County church but
was this just the art of Illusion for as
far as we know no records of a chapel or
congregation exist a quiet choir indeed
come to think of it it seems that
everything within this 60-acre Orchard
was destined to be silenced one way or
another by violent force or even by
conscious decision-making see while the
SCP Foundation has had a long track
record of subduing anomalies by methods
of capture and containment not all
things are suited for locks and chains
scp-4608 is better covered with a story
than a tar a fruitless field that once
produced at an unmanageable pace is now
rendered incapable of supporting growth
most will think it's due to a toxic
spell in Truth The Spill wasn't that of
chemicals on soil but rather corpses on
crops a week after receiving the
photograph of 4608-1 site 81 sent a
three-man investigation team into Milan
their Adventure was equally abrupt a
story with no reportable beginning or
middle but simply a predictable end
after four days of no communication the
foundation presumed the three agents no
different than their steak dinner dead
meat and only then after the
foundation's failure to solve the case
was it understood that what we were to
be looking for wasn't people at all but
rather answers to more nebulous
questions what's really happening here
and why is this happening following the
loss of communication with the
investigation team site 81 dispatched a
high risk Response Team Mobile Strike
Force Bravo 7 AKA Hometown Heroes these
men had all the makings of Heroes and
they were determined to prove themselves
worthy of the title while the alpha
Squad moved north towards the incident
site beta Squad headed east and Gamma
Squad hurried West the crews covering
all directions of the compass but South
a coincidentally symbolic gesture as if
to say we will not be taken down the
mission was simple in theory find out
what happened to the previous team and
why but alas missions never are as easy
as their objective statement reads in
practice some might even call them
impossible as Alpha neared the incident
they noticed the Shadows on the ground
beneath them did not resemble the shape
of the leaves in the canopy above they
heard small drops of liquid tap tap tap
on their helmets yet it wasn't raining
was it Alpha One ran his finger across
the top of his helmet and then examined
the residue left on his skin it was
raining just not water oh God upon
looking up he witnessed the reasons for
both irregularities bodies hung from
branches by their intestines casting
shadow puppets with their lifeless limbs
blood dripped down like a leaky faucet
what did this but before he could even
Ponder the answer he heard a loud shriek
from his radio so loud that the radio
itself vibrated shaking its way loose
from his hand and falling to the dirt he
bent down and picked it up and this time
gripped tighter as if to tell whoever
was responsible for that noise that they
will not get away that easily he and his
crew followed this sound like a game of
Marco Polo blind to what may be ahead
they extended their guns and pointed
them into the distant tree line like
zombie arms reaching outward in the pool
towards the Resonance of Polo a small
comfort in a giant game of distress as
they press forward Alpha Squad proceeded
past all signs that pointed them back
stepping over dead bodies like puddles
on a rainy day soon they found
themselves crouching down next to human
remains attending brief and hurried
funerals for all their closest comrades
torn between staying to pay respect and
marching along to earn it the chest
cavities of the Fallen had been ripped
open and filled with apples a grim
foresight into what they were up against
but nothing they could have ever
imagined would prepare them for what
they were about to see and they wouldn't
have to wait long another loud shriek
from alpha one's radio it shot free from
his grip and landed again in the dirt
the squad tried to ignore the
metaphorical implications of this
reoccurrence quickly picking up the
radio and trucking it off as if the
five-second rule applied equally to
communication systems as candy bars they
press forward maybe out of Bravery maybe
out of Shame of going back and while
moving through the tree
they began to notice something alarming
etched on their bark what was it there
were unnaturally deep grooves on the
base of almost every one of the trees
but what exactly were they from
scratches from an animal or beast
infection Decay their eyes Drew closer
but proximity brought them no Clarity
these sigils and symbols could be dated
back to a cult Norse religion but in
that moment they were incomprehensible
to the men yet the message even if
misinterpreted was very clear beware
another shrieking cry over the radio the
bullets the bullets aren't they're not
working they can't they can't penetrate
the bark chaos ensued as an scp-4608-1
flash by Alpha 5 where's Alpha 5 a
moment later they will wish they had
never asked but when they tilt their
chins and looked up they find Alpha 5
bisected and hanging by his intestines
from the trees the grass is no Greener
over on the east side of the orchard
where beta Squad gets lunged at by an
scp-4608-1 their defense are futile but
they fight nonetheless sending rounds to
the attacker's chest leading to nothing
if scp-4608 had a health meter it
wouldn't have budged in the slightest
understanding the negligible impact
their efforts and assessing their
injuries beta Squad scurries to retreat
to an abandoned Chapel taking a brief
Refuge from war only later to be named
quickly they barricade the door in the
chapel beta 9 tends to Beta 6's wounds
who is in the worst shape of them all
cut bloody and beaten as he lays there
grimacing he shines his flashlight up
and down the Chapel's walls until he
finds a reason to stop and holds it
steady illuminated is an assortment of
human skulls and if this wasn't dramatic
enough he then spotted apple seeds
embedded in beta 6's wounds apple seeds
that were starting to sprout beta 9 gave
him to him straight This is Gonna Hurt
he drew his knife from his belt and
lowered it into his comrades wounds beta
9 dug into flesh and Bone picking the
seeds out one by
beta 6's scream shook the Chapel's
stained glass windows as beta 1 stood
guard he saw a blur rip past him as if
life had suddenly been turned up to
three times speed he spun around in a
circle to try and keep his eyes on it
but as his vision refocused he saw beta
9 was now dead he then shifted his gaze
to Beta 6 who was looking less and less
Human by the second branches began
sprouting out of his body like an
all-consuming magic beanstalk out of his
chest out of his eyes out of his mouth
and when there were no more orifices to
exit his body exploded making way for
the new form that had overtaken him the
barrage of branches broke through the
windows only two of them were lucky to
be on the outskirts of inertia outside
Gamma 1 was on his knees thanking his
dead comrade for the grenade he stole
from his back pocket I could always
count on you to have my back even in
death one hand holding a grenade and the
other on his radio Gamma 1 called off
alpha 7. alpha 7 request for backup
rescinded go grab a burger I'll take it
from here Gamma 1 slowly glanced up and
locked dies with
scp-4608-2 a large apple tree with 13
human faces embedded into it a perennial
plant with great Powers a gymnosperm
that had found a voice blood poured from
scp-4608-2's empty eye sockets Gamma 1
smirks get some eye drops sicko he
crawled over to the Beast the faces
began yelling at him in Indescribable
tongues let me refer you to a speech
therapist he jokes as he pulls the pin
of the grenade and throws it towards the
largest of the 13 mouths
scp-4608-2 chokes on the grenade forcing
it to inhale deeply the strength of its
lungs pulling Gamma 1 toward it and
sucking him in the grenade goes off
scp-4608-2 explodes the surrounding
trees scream and combust the orchard
Goes Up in Flames the bodies of the
Fallen are given an appropriate
cremation gamma 1's radio lays face up
in the dirt The Voice rattles it away
it's Alpha 7 Gamma One Gamma One are you
there can you hear me please please it's
Alpha seven please Gamma One on October
16th 1947. Gamma 1 was recovered by the
Allen County Fire Department unconscious
and suffering from exhaustion and smoke
inhalation the site 81 concealment team
took control of the situation and
quarantined the area using the cover
story of a toxic chemical Hazard the
members of MTF Bravo 7 were postinously
awarded the foundation star for their
efforts during the neutralization of
scp-4608 and so the one question that
remains is how how did
scp-4608-1 become so dangerous and how
did its danger slip by for so many years
is its volatility by Nature design or
consequence could it be that the
foundation failed to understand the
complexity of this creation during
Chapman's lifetime there were no
accidents or fatalities coming from
scp-4608 yet there is no reason to
believe that
scp-4608-1 wasn't always capable of
maybe it always was capable of mass
murders but simply had no reason to kill
what if the Logging Company never
stepped foot on that land never brought
out their sharp blades and heavy
machinery what if this perilous Orchard
was in fact docile but provoked what if
the proverbial tree only falls in the
woods when we force our philosophy on it
though
scp-4608-2 spoke an unidentifiable
sounds the noises were always recognized
and recorded as language it spoke with
intent even if misunderstood what it
screamed is still unclear were they
pleased for help or messages of hate and
would one even be worse than the other
John Chapman might argue when facing
heavy machinery and trained artillery
would raising your voice even be a moral
decision at all is fight or flight
imbued not just in blood but also in
bark the SCP Foundation has a long
history of experience with humanoid
anomalies from simple reality Benders
like scp-2 39 to strange transplants
from other universes like
scp-2273 but one of the oldest strangest
and most lethal humanoid anomalies in
the foundation's considerable cabinet
isn't a superhuman or a soldier it is a
man known only as her hirog on first
glance
scp-542's containment protocol is
seemingly standard he is allowed to
request personal items and furniture for
a cell so long as they are blunt and
cannot be used to cut skin reasonable
enough and many such requests have been
granted the ones denied include nail
files Clippers and a surgery kit which
has been set aside for testing only But
continuing scp-542 requires some special
attention too a blood transfusion every
week on request and even an organ
transplant conducted by Foundation
doctors should any of his own organs
begin to fail
scp-542 offers to do the surgery himself
but what is repeatedly denied to
understand the story of her hirog we
must look back through time to several
years before
scp-542's containment over the past
three years there have been a violent
string of murders Across America England
and Germany Interpol and the FBI are
stumped not only by the wide range of
attacks anywhere from 45 to 60 murders
across three countries but by the brutal
nature of the attacks the victims were
found in various states of disassembly
body parts missing and tissue removed
they set up crime scenes and conducted
complex investigations but they were
simply unable to find their man in one
month four people in Germany were
assaulted with the muscle tissue and
Bone removed from all of their limbs
three of them died from their injuries
before help could arrive and the fourth
was an American woman staying at a shady
German Hotel the only reason she
narrowly survived the horrific attack
was because of the actions of her
neighbor a foundation agent passing
through town he heard sounds of fighting
in the room next door at three in the
morning and broke down the door to help
unaware of the horrific scene he would
find a huge misshapen man best described
as a Frankenstein's monster his skin was
a patchwork of different shades stitched
and grafted together his chest was
sunken in his arms were grotesquely long
for his body and his face was skeletal
and gaunt this creature that would come
to be named scp-542 was hunched over the
fully conscious woman vivisecting her
leg to remove the sinew and Bone and
shot the agent pulled his weapon and
fired at the creature which escaped
through the window unharmed the
authorities were called and the woman
survived although without her right leg
just before being anesthetized the woman
provided a statement to the foundation
she had been staying in Germany for a
few days when she saw strange man on her
usual bus one day even though it was
summer the man was draped and wrapped in
layers of heavy coats jackets and a hat
though his face completely obscured the
woman could tell he was staring at her
from the back of the bus thinking it was
just some creep she ignored him and got
off at her stop for three days she
continued to take the bus and ignore the
strange man sitting in the back then on
the fourth day when she got off the bus
that night and went to her hotel room
she found the window open and the lights
off and assumed she had been burglarized
but as soon as she opened the door she
realized she wasn't alone too freakishly
long arms with disjointed hands grabbed
her ankles from under the bed and
brought her crashing to the floor before
she knew what was happening she was tied
to the bed and the hulking Hunchback was
retrieving a surgical set and sharpening
his Knives and Tools fearing the worse
she began to scream and the agent hurt
her but but by the time he broke in and
shot his weapon the creature had already
done too much damage to her leg the
victim was anesthetized and told her leg
had been amputated in a car crash the
foundation took over the investigation
from Interpol realizing this wasn't some
regular serial killer this was a
creature a predator and to find it they
had to hunt scp-542 like a predator
after a long tracking in Manhunt across
Europe
scp-542 was brought into Foundation
custody and Research into this creature
could begin to understand the story of
her hirog the researchers were expecting
an animal or a monster something they
could study and dissect which is why
they were so shocked when the monster
began speaking in tongues German French
polish before settling on English all in
a sharp German accent the Beast was
introducing itself
German for Mr surgeon preliminary
investigations revealing much about
scp-542 and confirmed the agent's
initial impression was correct her hirok
is a modern Frankenstein's monster his
Anatomy has been warped and malformed as
the agent observed his skin is a
patchwork of large chunks of skin
grafted or sewn to each other no two of
which seem to come from the same person
his rib cage is Warped and twisted with
all the ribs jutting out in different
directions and both his arms are
different sizes though both are
incredibly muscular and far too long for
his body attached to each is a hand but
filled with far more joints than any
normal hand allowing him to bend his
fingers in almost any direction his
spine is hunched and twisted like a
snake and the skin stretched tight over
his skull reveals a sunken Cranium and a
mouth with far far too many teeth none
of them from the same source and not all
of them Hume and these are all simply
the externally obvious and most
grotesque modifications Foundation staff
have conducted intense medical research
ranging from x-rays to comprehensive DNA
testing
scp-542's bone and muscle structures are
asymmetrical revealing the left and
right sides of his body come from
different sources in fact they reveal
that almost all of his organs and body
parts have been replaced with other body
parts from different sources his DNA is
heavily fragmented beyond all logic by
any reasonable measure scp-542 should
have died a long time ago instead he is
able to accept many blood types and
organ transplants without so much as
discomfort much less the serious
autoimmune response that any normal
person would get not to mention he is
able to stay perfectly aware even while
performing complex brain surgery on
himself her hirerg's history is as
enigmatic and mysterious as the question
of how he remains alive he claims he was
once a simple doctor from Germany
dreadfully normal until the Great War
began the foundation has deduced this to
mean that he began his modifications to
his body between the world wars but it
appears her hirig wasn't just a monster
on the outside he claims to have worked
for the Nazis in World War II as they
conducted brutal human experimentation
which he described as boring the exact
nature and timeline of how he modified
himself without dying at some point is
similarly mysterious he professes that
he didn't work alone for more complex
surgeries such as implanting his second
heart or replacing parts of his spinal
cord he had a team of helpers who and
where these surgical assistants are now
is a mystery if they're even alive after
all the foundation has ample evidence
her hirig is able and willing to kill
people for their parts After All This
exhaustive research on scp-542 you'd be
forgiven for thinking that he is some
kind kind of mad scientists driven
insane by his experimentation on his own
body while no one can answer why hirag
kills except himself he is almost
frighteningly sane this hulking
monstrosity enjoys reading his Anatomy
textbooks which he requests on a regular
basis along with filling out crossword
puzzles in German he's friendly too
described as surprisingly Pleasant by
the research team he holds long
intellectual conversations on topics
ranging from science and biology and
medicine to politics and history which
he seems to recount with startling
accuracy in fact tissue testing has
failed to return a definitive age for
the surgeon he's incredibly skilled at
the game of chess and the research team
is allowed to play with him as a method
of interview
scp-542 displays fluency in a variety of
European languages though he prefers his
supposedly native German at first the
research team was enthused with his
presence even if he won was a little
terrifying having a brilliant doctor to
converse with was a great distraction
for them his ability to heal from
intense surgery with almost no organ
rejection or allergic reactions was
considered a medical miracle and rather
than locking him up and throwing away
the key the research team decided to use
him to try and harness this incredible
power for modern medicine his books and
notes captured along with him reveals
surgical techniques and methods far more
advanced than considered possible when
they were written for his part scp-542
was happy to comply he enjoyed
performing surgery on himself with an
audience using himself as a living
cadaver to explain his manner of surgery
and the functions of the body
unfortunately observing him this close
carried a risk none of the researchers
realized until it was too late you see
her hirig isn't just a friendly old
surgeon his body runs off second-hand
parts and is constantly failing organs
stop functioning blood flow ceases parts
of his body grow gankronous and necrotic
scp-542 is able to anomalously detect
when this is happening he is perfectly
and acutely aware of his own bodily
functions like digestion and perstasis
and he knows exactly when one of his
organs is starting to give up or his
flesh is beginning to Decay when this
happens the surgeon undergoes a drastic
transformation his Pleasant exterior
evaporates grows Moody and withdrawn
snapping at people and avoiding
conversation he spends long periods of
time observing people using his ability
to sense how well their body is and then
when he senses an opening he's strikes
just like his murders in Europe he picks
the body of his victims clean of their
body parts he needs and lets them die of
blood loss then he performs the surgery
to replace his own failing organs with
the new ones and returns to his usual
demeanor this monstrous Jekyll Hyde
relationship is in purely need based
either the research team has discovered
that her hirag will also dissect people
simply for the joy of the act in one
regrettable incident a sewing kid was
left behind in this cell several hours
later guards discovered a d-class sewn
to the mattress in
scp-542's cell with the surgeon
carefully and gleefully extracting his
organs
scp-542 her hirig is a walking
Encyclopedia of medical and surgical
knowledge but all that knowledge comes
from experimentation on himself and on
unwilling victims the foundation is put
into use in certain projects but all
activity with him is to be strictly
monitored and regulated despite
appearances
scp-542 isn't a person he is a predator
and an exceptionally skilled and
dangerous one at that one moment of
inattentiveness can result in a fate
much worse than death around him but you
can rest assured that if something does
happen Your Parts won't go to waste
picture this if you'll excuse that
foreshadowing pun you're at your local
City Mall in Ohio a place that's never
still every time you go there no matter
what time of day or day of the week it's
always full of people all bustling about
shopping eating dashing past one another
maybe presumably like everyone else you
came in to get some specific item or you
might just be browsing heck you could be
there for a casual date or to grab a
bite to eat at the food court that's
when you remember you need to have your
picture taken it could be that your
passport is about to expire or your
driver's license hasn't been updated
since you moved whatever the reason
lucky for you there's a photo booth
right here in the mall take your own
photo boasts the sign on the outside of
the cramped cubicle a list of
instructions below describing just how
quick and easy the process is you take a
look at the price list feed the right
amount of money into the slot and take a
seat inside pulling the curtain closed
do you straighten your back look
directly into the lens a short countdown
appears on the screen three two one a
flash bursts from the bulb above the
lens filling the booth and leaving those
white spots floating in your vision for
a few moments you head back out of the
cubicle waiting to pick up the glossy
paper with your photos on it as it
starts rapidly printing them off you
wanted a two by two four total pictures
of your face but then as it finishes
Printing and you inspect the pictures
turning the paper in your hands you're
met with a surprise an unnerving one to
say the least the pictures don't show
your face fact it barely looks like a
human face at all it has your clothes
and your hair but the whole image has
been warped not just out of focus but
completely disproportional annoyed that
you spend your money only to receive a
highly distorted image you wander off to
find another Booth throwing the unusable
picture in the nearest trash can now
sure you might write off something like
that as just an odd occurrence a freak
of Technology caused by faulty Machinery
in desperate need of repair but what you
don't know in fact you won't even
realize until it's too late is what
really just happened when you sat down
and that flash went off taking your
picture and printing it off as a warped
unrecognizable mess something was born
located at the end of a series of long
winding concrete stairs and kept out of
sight behind doors marked keep out and
staff only is a lower level of them all
hidden in this dark off-limits area that
no member of the public is permitted to
access there is a service door or
somewhere in the southwest corner of the
third sub-basement just taking a look at
it you could easily imagine nothing at
all interesting behind it like a power
generator or a storage room but if you
were to push it open and Venture inside
you'd stumble upon something you would
never have expected in your wildest
dreams or more accurately your most
disturbing nightmares beyond that
service door is a cavern hardly the
first thing you'd assume to be secreted
away underneath a city's shopping mall
although if you're into cave jumping it
would be ill-advised to take a
spelunking Adventure down there the
entire Cavern isn't actually part of our
world it's an extra dimensional space
think of it as its own little pocket
universe that has somehow become
connected to ours and can now be
accessed through this doorway if it
helps you can even picture our universe
as a big soap bubble with a slightly
smaller bubble attached to it in
actuality it's infinitely more
complicated and looks nothing like two
bubbles of different sizes but like we
said if it helps to picture it that way
then go right ahead if you were brave
enough or naive enough to venture deeper
into this cave and not to be put off by
its walls that look like they've been
carved from Pure limestone you would
have had to watch your step to avoid a
nasty fall within the large cave space
is a deep dark pit a rocky conduit in
the ground seemingly leading down into
the Earth but taking a closer look the
walls of this pit aren't made of rock
they don't even match the Limestone that
the rest of the cavernous room looks to
be cut from the surface of the pit is
coated in a slimy substance closer to
something biological coming from a
living thing rather than being carved
out of rock depending on your
familiarity with the texture you might
even say this substance is not all that
far off from the appearance and feel of
human fat tissue although you probably
shouldn't reach in to try and touch it
for yourself least of all because the
walls of the pit are constantly
secreting a corrosive substance like
acid that could easily break down your
body by its molecules painfully burning
you until you melt it down into soup but
there's something else down there lots
of somethings as a matter of fact in the
moment you took that photo sitting in
the safety of the booth in the mall
above a new something found itself Born
Into the pit it looks almost exactly
like you but its face is all wrong you
could even say distorted like a
photograph that didn't quite come out
right the abnormalities in its face
could take the form of lacerations cuts
and open wounds or bloody welts by
looking in a mirror at a twisted injured
version of yourself or this imperfect
copy might have growth bulging out from
its head covering its facial features to
make it virtually unrecognizable as a
clone of you then again maybe it'll just
come out missing everything no eyes
mouth nose just a blank expressionless
mask on a body otherwise identical to
yours and what does this thing this
clone do now that it finds itself in a
pit filled with other writhing imperfect
copies of everyone that's ever sat to
have their picture taken in that photo
booth well what would you do you would
try to get out as quickly as possible
and that's what it will start doing
while you're going about the rest of
your day maybe stopping off at a few
stores in the mall or complaining to the
customer service staff about that faulty
photo booth it's already started
climbing its fingernails are digging
into that fleshy tissue that coats the
walls of the pit as the copy drags its
imperfect body upwards crawling over the
others around it that are trying to do
the exact same there's no telling just
how many of them are down there how many
misshapen heads and deformed faces your
clone has had to barge past and climb
over as they all pile deep down within
their hole in the ground and what it's
the worst part of all this it's not just
the climb the fact that your copy has to
fight its way out of the pit making the
near impossible Ascent to make it to the
surface no the worst part is that you
have no idea it's happening you're
completely oblivious that a distorted
clone of you is raking its nails against
walls of fat tissue clambering up from
underneath the ground and even more so
you have no idea what it wants to do
when it gets free and finds you the SCP
Foundation has long since been keeping
an eye on the anomaly that they
themselves have designated as scp-715
given that the photo booth itself was
connected to the extra dimensional space
buried deep below the mall removing it
isn't really an option sure they could
have easily have cordoned it off and put
up signs saying the booth was out of
order to deter members of the public
from trying to use it but this was the
SCP Foundation after all they needed to
run tests figure out exactly what this
anomaly did and how it ticked Gerald
Patton had been a rising star at the
foundation a promising researcher who
had long been proving his medal since he
first became part of the organization
for a Time the higher-ups at the
foundation had planned to attach the
researcher to the scp-2090 project
studying a basketball player who somehow
gained anomalous Powers however hearing
about the photo booth in the Ohio City
Mall he turned down this request to
instead join the team researching
scp-715 certain high-level staff of the
SCP Foundation noted this to be strange
Patton had never turned down a promotion
before as the scp-2090 project would
have offered him better pay and more
vacation time in order to observe the
photo booth closely without alerting the
public to their presence Foundation
staff on site were disguised to blend in
with civilians and some posed as retail
staff employed at the mall come closing
time once everyone else that worked
there or who had been shopping
throughout the day had finally left the
foundation researchers were free to run
the their tests and investigate the
anomalous photo booth it was the night
of a routine Sweep All staff members on
site were required to test the
surrounding area for reality warping
anomalies The Sweep was mandatory for
the entire team assigned to scp-715 yet
quite unusually researcher Patton didn't
report in for the procedure the
higher-ups at the foundation decided to
let this indiscretion slide though after
all there were a lot of personnel
involved in the process so patent was
let off the hook in fact the few
disparities in Patton's behavior only
became more apparent when Dr Agatha
writes began to more closely collate and
process the files and information on the
Personnel on site she was the research
head on the scp-715 project and quickly
noticed a few things that didn't add up
about researcher Gerald Patton his
rejection of the offer to join the
scp-2090 project and refusal to attend a
routine reality bending anomaly sweep
might have seemed like unrelated
incidents at first but both would have
brought the researcher into contact with
technology that the foundation used
specifically to detect any distortions
to reality if he had taken the promotion
or been present for the sweep he too
would have been within the scope of this
specialized detection equipment yet both
times he managed to avoid being put in
such a position what the hell was Patton
hiding and what would show up if a
detector was pointed at him Dr Wrights
was growing ever more suspicious of
researcher Patton and his behavior
however it was when she learned he had
secretly tested the photo booth himself
that she decided to take matters into
her own hands in order to get to the
bottom of what Gerald was up to she had
to mull it over and think about things
cautiously she couldn't confront him
directly at least not yet even the
evidence she already had that Patton had
seemingly twice avoided situations
involving the use of reality Distortion
detection equipment wasn't enough to
prove for certain he was hiding
something though both instances could
have been caused by something completely
unrelated Gerald could have rejected his
promotion purely because he was more
interested in scp-715 than joining the
scp-2090 project and even Foundation
Personnel needed sick days or skipped
work because of a hangover without
telling anyone which could explain why
he was absent during the sweep of them
all but Agatha wasn't convinced it felt
like the two instances lined up too
closely they felt far too similar to be
an utterly random coincidence even if
Gerald wasn't up to anything dangerous
the only way to know for sure was to
observe him but without drawing
attention to it we deny anything act
completely differently maybe even flat
out lie if he knew someone was listening
or watching Agatha was forced to think
in a way that was as calculated as she
was certain Gerald had been his quarters
were located in a secluded part of the
sub-basement a level above where the
fleshy pit could be found almost all the
foundation Personnel assigned to scpc
715 slept somewhere on site their
presence they're masked from the
ordinary Mall employees taking care not
to be detected they had installed doors
with a key card system meaning only
members of their own staff could access
the living quarters under the mall if
any civilians happen to stumble upon the
foundation and discover them then all it
took was the careful application of
amnestics to ensure that they wouldn't
remember a thing beeping her key card at
the door Agatha slipped into the living
area it mostly consisted of a narrow
Corridor with rows of doors on either
side behind each one was a cramped room
each only big enough for one person a
bunk to sleep in and a sink with a
mirror above it Gerald's room was the
furthest from the entrance right down at
the end of the corridor as far from
everyone else as he could get although
it also meant if he came back from
testing early then he'd be more likely
to catch Agatha leaving his room and
walking back along the row it would be
hard to come up with an excuse as to
what she was doing anywhere near his
quarters especially as her room was
right behind the very first door right
next to the entrance all this was
rushing through Dr Wright's mind as she
squeezed into Patton's room in actual
fact the Interior Space of them was so
limited that they were even smaller than
most ship cabins her hand had been
clasped around the handle of a metal
case which she sat down on Gerald's
empty bed unclasping the clips that held
it closed Agatha opened up the case and
took out what was held inside the inner
layer of protective foam it was the
Fullman breaker anomalous Optical
enhancement device a piece of the
specialized apparatus that Foundation
researchers used to record and identify
any person or object that might be
exhibiting anomalous properties it
utilized state-of-the-art Optical
enhancement technology and could be used
to detect whether a subject was causing
any Distortion to the reality around it
by accessing visual spectrums that were
normally imperceivable to the naked
human eye or sometimes even unobservable
in this Dimension Agatha looked around
the tiny cabin given the limited space
she was also short on options as to
where she could hide the device without
it being easily noticed it was also
imperative that researcher Patton had no
idea he was under observation Dr Wrights
looked over to the sink in the corner
the mirror just above it sure it was a
tactic taken straight out of the big
book of spy novel cliches but it would
work the advanced Spectrum capabilities
of the optical enhancement device would
be able to record patent through the
glass luckily the entire living quarters
had been pretty hastily built which
meant it took little effort for Agatha
to loosen the screws holding the mirror
in place but that's when she heard the
distinctive beep of the door to the
living quarters followed by the gradual
footsteps getting closer and closer it
might not have been Gerald but there was
also an equal chance that it could have
been acting as fast as she could Agatha
placed the optical enhancement device on
the wall and covered it with the mirror
frantically trying to screw it back into
place as quick as she could the echoing
noise of someone approaching sounded as
if they were almost right outside the
cabin door by the time Dr Wright had
tightened the screws enough to keep the
mirror in place giving a quick final
scan of the room making sure nothing
looked too conspicuous she grabbed the
empty case and smoothed out the duvet
where it had been laying leaving no
Trace that she had ever been there her
heart already racing it almost exploded
right out of her chest as she slipped
back out of the door to Patton's cabin
only to see him walking down the narrow
Corridor directly towards his room
towards her uh Dr writes Gerald greeted
with a staged smile though the suspicion
on his face was so unmistakable that
probably shown up clearly on camera
something I can help you with Patton
Agatha gave a plight nod back to the
researcher lifting the case behind her
back the one upside of the tight
Corridor was that Patton was so close to
her he couldn't see what she was hiding
the obvious downside being he might be
close enough to clock Dr Wright's
suspicion of him did you need something
patent chuckled sorry it's just what
were you doing in my quarters her heart
was still racing desperately trying to
form a plausible excuse somewhere in her
mind Agatha's freehand reached into her
pocket something brushing against her
fingertips would have to do hey you
dropped this she exclaimed pulling out a
20 Bill and handing it to Gerald a small
price to pay to keep her subterfuge
earlier on in the mall near scp-715 I
saw it fall out of your pocket I had
other matters to attend to down at
anyway I wanted to make sure you got it
back oh thank you Gerald blinked in
Surprise taking the money as she
squeezed past him and walked out of the
living quarters Agatha could barely stop
her hands from shaking although those
Tremors of nerves would have to become
the trembling of absolute horror when
she saw the footage that the optical
enhancement device collected Patton was
one of the creatures from the pit it
didn't seem possible he didn't even have
clearance to know about the pit and any
of the Clones or
scp-715-as that managed to claw their
way up to the surface were immediately
terminated by on-site security the
instances becoming known as scp-715bs if
they made it that far yet somehow patent
or whatever he really was had made it
through undetected but that was far from
the worst Discovery Dr Wrights would
make she used a number of the same
anomalous Optical enhancement devices to
observe the
scp-715-8 creatures within the pit only
to find that she and the other
researchers had made a grave mistake the
scp-715-as they were all humans but the
foundation had initially thought were
the distorted imperfect clone copies of
everyone who had used the scp-715 photo
booth were actually The Originals they
had been trying to climb back up because
they wanted to come home their places
taken by
scp-715-bs but none of those people now
Twisted disfigured and unrecognizable
were able to explain to the foundation
who they were and they'd been shot left
to fall back into the pit and die acting
fast Dr Wright's updated the
classification of scp-715 to ketter
although This was later rescinded back
to Safe the creature that looked like
researcher patent was apprehended and
brought in for interrogation after
learning the truth behind scp-715 the
photo booth was secured and locked up
permanently but as of now the project
investigating scp-715 has been put on
hold no one at the foundation wants to
admit their mistake that they now have
an extra dimensional pit full of
innocent distorted people or that they
have no idea where all their body
swapped counterparts
Diego had only just found this footing
when it gave out underneath him again
crashing to the ground he threw both
arms over his head just in time to
protect his skull from the reign of
Boulders that came down past him they
grazed his arms and Jarred painfully
against his muscles but it was better
than having them hit him in the head
without a moment to spare Diego got
straight up to his feet and continued
running back down the trail he had been
trying to follow the ground shifted and
lurched in all directions under him
threatening to throw off his balance at
any moment having lived in Chile his
whole life he had gotten used to
earthquakes but he had never been in the
center of one like this the problem was
that the trail he had been following to
get up here was disappearing fast as the
dust swirled into the air and boulders
Landing all around him he just had to
keep running in this direction and hope
for the best there weren't any other
options but suddenly he found himself
running uphill stumbling forwards Diego
tried desperately to get his bearings he
had spent the previous three hours
hiking up the mountains so how was it
that now that he had turned around and
gone back he was still going uphill it
was almost as if the ground was changing
shape beneath him as he ran dust filled
his lungs as he tried to wipe it away
from his burning eyes yes the ground was
definitely going uphill but it felt
almost as if it was lifting itself up
beneath him as if some tectonic plates
were grinding together creating a new
Mountain beneath his feet Diego lurched
unsteadily and grabbed the nearest rock
to keep his balance feeling the ground
lifting higher and higher beneath him
then all of a sudden the cloud of dust
broke and he was in fresh air Rising
ever higher into the sky the Andes
Mountains stabbed out of the clouds all
around him cutting beautiful shapes
across the Horizon he felt his own
Mountain steadily growing taller than
any of them he dropped down on all
floors and clutched at the ground in
Terror as he tried his best to take in
the shape of what he was now standing
upon how far would you go to prevent a
cosmic level disaster it's one thing to
save your friends and family from an
armed murderer it's another thing to
fight for your country in a world war we
can even just about imagine what it
means to fight for our planet to save
our species from climate change to save
our world from a meteorite but what
would a cosmic disaster look like a
Calamity is so Broad in scale that it
surpasses our ability to even perceive
the threat we could Point our most
advanced telescope into deep space and
look straight down the middle of it and
never know it was even there and if that
threat was not simply to the survival of
humanity or planet Earth but to the
survival of existence itself how far
would we go to prove invented what cruel
and inhumane measures would you take to
have such a threat or better yet how
many people would you kill to save the
world this debate is Raging right now as
you sit here and watch this video not
among the foundation but between two
scps so Grand in scale and so advanced
in nature that the foundation has no
option but to sit and listen as the pair
debate what to do with the human race
scp-4568-1 was not difficult to discover
once it started moving in fact it was
almost impossible to ignore earthquakes
have been tearing across South America
for centuries destroying homes taking
the lives of innocent people and
fundamentally changing the shape of our
planet itself what most people do not
realize however is that the fault line
running through the Andes mountain range
has actually largely been dormant during
this period the source of the
earthquakes has come from something far
more mysterious our innocent hiker Diego
had been spending the week walking among
the Andes when the earthquake struck you
would be forgiven for assuming as Diego
did that the ground Rising beneath his
feet was a new Mountain forming as the
tectonic plates clashed together but the
Staggering reality of the situation was
that he found himself hiking along the
back of
scp-4568-1 as the creature raised its
head into the air Diego saw the head of
a serpent lifting several kilometers
away from him its body stretched and
wound its way through the mountain range
filling the valleys and running beneath
his feet the scale of
scp-4568-1 is hard to convey measuring
over 500 kilometers in length this
serpent is longer than most U.S states
with a 20 kilometer width standing on
the back of it quite literally feels
like standing on a mountain range for
context The Horizon at sea level is
about 4.8 km away so multiply that by
four and you'll get a sense of just how
wide this thing is even small movements
from this SCP are enough to trigger
continent-wide earthquakes with tremors
being felt all the way around the world
upon the initial discovery of this SCP
the foundation was unable to determine
why it remains dormant for such long
periods and seems to only awaken
sporadically and for brief periods of
time that was until
scp-4568-2 was discovered it is little
wonder that the second serpent took so
long to be found its body is comprised
almost entirely of water sand algae and
steam does not show up on Sonar scans
and is incredibly difficult to detect in
the water even visually its form is
Loosely defined while stormant with
broadly similar measurements to
scp-4568-1 this serpent roams the South
Pacific Ocean any Marine creatures that
swim into the the scp's body find
themselves undergoing beneficial
mutations crabs grow extra Pinchers
Bottom Feeders grow larger mouths and
sharks find themselves developing
heightened senses and even extra hearts
these marine animals seem to undergo
virtually no distress and are free to
exit and re-enter the scp's body at any
point initially
scp-4568-2 was believed to be the
peaceful one of the pair both serpents
seem to become active at the same time
while on land
scp-4568-1 would wreak havoc with
magnitude 7 earthquakes in major
metropolitan areas the sea Serpent's
function was less well understood
employing resonant frequencies and
vibrations this SCP was able to give its
watery body a distinct form as it rose
up from the ocean and towered above the
waves in order to maintain its shape and
control its movements this SCP employed
a huge amount of energy however the
foundation quickly observed that it was
rarely able to maintain its form for
very long as soon as the sea serpent
rose out of the water its mountainous
twin would begin to move sending Tremors
around the world that disrupted the
frequency needed for
scp-4568-2 to remain animate exhausted
and unable to maintain its shape the sea
serpent would fall into another period
of dormancy gliding lazily through the
oceans but this dormances suited the
foundation without the constant seismic
Tremors researchers could work fast two
operating bases were set up to monitor
each as CP two mirrored bases with
mirrored teams in constant communication
with one another as soon as one team
made a discovery it was conveyed to the
others and vice versa one operating base
was set up high in the Andes Mountains
specifically designed to be as
earthquake proof as possible capable of
withstanding earthquakes on up to 9.9
magnitude meanwhile in the South Pacific
Ocean an underwater Research Center was
built just above the seabed with regular
vessels drifting out into the unknown to
gather whatever data they could about
the great SCP
several early findings stood out firstly
scp-4568-1 appeared to have a very
different internal structure from its
twin researchers initially assumed that
the creature would be largely composed
of Earth minerals and rock as its
exterior appearance suggested however
scans of its body indicated the presence
of what can only be assumed to be
artificially created components great
gears resembling Clockwork structures
and even rudimentary circuitry were
present throughout the creature's body
the function or origin of these gears
has yet to be determined especially as
there is no evident way that their
movement corresponds to the autonomy and
movement of the serpent itself the far
more striking Discovery however game
when the SCP Foundation discovered a way
to communicate with the two beasts ultra
low frequency waves capable of traveling
vast distances even light years were
discovered to be emitted from the two
serpents heads at intermittent period
the foundation had to develop some of
the largest antenna ever created to pick
up these frequencies and interpret the
data coming through them what they found
were two twins locked in a fierce debate
about the fate of humanity and the
universe itself it was only then that
the motivations of these two serpents
started to make sense in 2010 almost as
soon as the foundation was able to tap
into the frequency they were contacted
directly by
scp-4568-1
Foundation I know that you can hear me I
will not apologize for my actions I know
that I am the reason that millions of
your kind face their demise I know your
pain and I feel it too but I shall never
apologize for it I simply ask you to
listen to myself and to my word cannot
be translated you are curious you can be
patient exercised effect and you may one
day understand and listen the foundation
did efforts to contain or destroy the
two serpents were put on the back burner
instead Foundation agents prioritize
spreading disinformation across South
America and Beyond about the source of
these earthquakes the two serpents are
far too large and far too powerful to
overcome or contain instead the
foundation prioritized the use of
amnestic drugs disinformation and the
creation of Fringe conspiracy groups to
discredit any claims of the Serpent's
respective existences meanwhile some of
the most senior leadership figures in
the foundation were and still are locked
in a fierce debate as to what to do with
the twin serpents by listening to the
communication between the two scps the
foundation discovered that
scp-4568-2 is intent on wiping out the
entire human race the only thing that
has prevented it from being able to do
so thus far has been the existence of
the other serpent every time that
scp-4568-2 begins to mount an attack on
Humanity its land-bearing twin triggers
enormous earthquakes to disrupt its
progress but why would the sea serpent
want to destroy the human race as
Foundation generals gathered in the deep
sea operations base
scp-4568-2 came to the observation
window to look them in the eyes as it
told them I am sure you can see it how
your world dies a little bit more every
day mostly by your own hand no you
poisoned the oceans tamed the rivers
black in the skies you do not need
angels of death to destroy your world
but there is something else I see it in
the bottom of your eyes something
Unforgettable
unconceivable ideas
this and impossible colors do you think
I will let you dry the rest of the world
down with yourselves do you think I will
leave this world my world to Die In
Flames
it's it sees your world and it comes in
fives since this Revelation the
foundation has poured countless hours
and resources into trying to identify a
cosmic threat for well over a decade
many of the smartest scientists the
world has to offer have looked to the
night sky scanning for this impossible
color this shroud of Madness but to no
avail some within the foundation believe
the serpent is lying trying to make up
an excuse to justify its genocide but
information from
scp-4568-1 seems to confirm everyone's
worst fears your minds burn bread
Foundation all of humanity shines from
this rock like a candle in a dark room
it sees you an idea exists only because
something thought of it have you ever
considered how such terrible Concepts
could have been given for what kind of
atrocious mind could even think about it
humans cannot conceive the colorless
green what if you are playing into this
creature's hands there appears to be an
underlying implication that ideas are
the source of power somehow this
colorless green this unimaginable Cosmic
threat seems to be a monstrous idea
incarnate but whose idea Humanities
there is a deep lore that the two
serpents discuss with one another one
that makes little sense even to this day
to the foundation they talk of gods and
goddesses deities of Flesh of Steel and
gears and of the fives quite what these
creatures are if they are even creatures
at all is a mystery to the foundation
researchers have not discovered a way of
communicating back with the two serpents
directly attempts to mimic their
language or transmit signals asking
questions to them have largely been
ignored instead they address you
identity and the foundation as a whole
seeming to take the view of the human
race as being a collective hive mind one
that they are evidently able to tap into
the pair seem uninterested in informing
us as to exactly what this threat is or
explaining who the gods and goddesses
are perhaps they assume we know these
things already or more likely they
believe that our Consciousness is not
yet capable of perceiving the scale and
depth of the concepts that they are
debating what is clear however is their
shared understanding that if Humanity
were to be eliminated the candle was to
be blown out this Cosmic threat would
pass by the pair have names trenten is
the land serpent while remaining dormant
much of the time in an enormous Cave
System beneath the Andes Mountains this
serpent seems Keen to help the
foundation in some way kaikai the sea
serpent is intent on sacrificing the
human race for a greater good one far
beyond our understanding speaking to the
foundation in the Andes Mountains
fronten gave a short speech that served
both as encouragement and a terrible
warning of the darkness to come the
the something I Like About You
Foundation about the mankind while it is
easy to just take the simplest path to
just give up there will always be some
among you who refuse this path who do
the right thing maybe not all of you are
this strong but I can see it in your
methods those so-called containment
procedures there will always be someone
who stands up against the dog even if it
takes a thousand million years to emerge
Victorious maybe you can stop the thief
after all ideas can be killed with
better ideas even if it takes a thousand
million years we've covered a lot here
on this channel and what you might have
noticed about the nature of our
discoveries is that knowledge is best
broken down before digested which is to
say if you are to learn how to assemble
a computer it may benefit you also to
see one taken apart when you do so
you'll notice in front of you not a
computer at all but a collection of
individual Parts it's in understanding
these distinctive Parts in isolation
that helps us shape our awareness of
their marriage and how they cooperate
with one another to become their
Collective self sure this may be good in
practice but then tell me how do we
comprehend a whole that is composed of
Parts unwilling to isolate themselves
from the rest because let's face it not
all things let alone as CPS can be torn
apart for the convenience of our study
no matter the subject we seek to
understand it may choose to resist our
deconstruction by one way or another
landmarks like the temples of Malta and
the Pyramid of Jose are held together by
our respect monuments like the Statue of
Liberty are held together by copper the
family was held together by Charles
Manson but it's not always the
preservation of history or elements of
the periodic table or Psychopaths that
reject humans wishes to disassemble far
stronger than forces of nuts and bolts
are that of character and loyalty and
scp-2085 is welded together by exactly
that
scp-2085 is a militant Anarchist
organization consisting of six
cybernetically enhanced individuals A1
through A5 and B operating under the
name kuroi usagi shiden or more commonly
known as the black rabbit company as
scp-2085-a subjects are five adult
female augmented humans designated
scp-2085-a-1 through
scp-2085-8-5 subjects are genetic
chimeras each with an estimated 6 to 10
different Gene donors they are fluent in
Japanese Mandarin Chinese Cantonese
Korean Russian and English with
additional languages varying by
individual subjects display an array of
genetic and cybernetic enhancements
including genetic splices of felis
Caddis physiology that is having
cat-like ears tails and hair these tails
are prehensile and capable of holding
small objects so if you're accusing one
of them of stealing your pen don't just
go searching their pockets they also
have grip pads on hands and feet in case
they ever did decide to retire from
Anarchy and take up surfing their
impressive features don't stop there if
they haven't already put James Bond's
gadgets to game yet just wait Daniel
Craig is about to look like Dora the
Explorer
scp-2085-8-1-8-5 all have ocular
implants with thermal vision heads-up
display and recording functionality also
noted our carbon nanoweave muscle fiber
augmentation reinforced endoskeleton and
brain computer interface with internal
hard drive the list goes on each Etc
more elaborate than the next yet what
stands out most about them is not a
weapon but an attitude these six members
although now held in isolation from one
another do not show any signs of
splitting up not even when under the
heavy pressure of the foundation's
interrogation agents spend their hours
looking for cracks to dig their fingers
into trying to get one to betray the
other and reveal sensitive information
but when asked to Spill the Beans
scp-2085 screws the lid on tighter they
remain as a whole resistant to our
deconstruct destruction the agents get
nowhere with their investigation and
with each minute wasted it's another
victory for scp-2085 the hours go on and
they keep stacking up W's building
momentum day after day growing stronger
and stronger as a unit as the foundation
tries to tear the group apart they
respond with even greater resistance and
this style of resistance is unique to
each member imagine you are confronting
scp-2085-8-2 she is talkative and so you
think you might get somewhere you are
all ears but what
scp-2085-8-2 sees isn't ears but trots
and she is happy to feed you her slop
she talks and talks and you listen
closer and closer but all you are
getting is misinformation false names
inaccurate stories dates that don't add
up you focus and follow along only to
find yourself having run a marathon all
the way to a dead and now you are faced
with
scp-2085-8-5 who takes a different more
nonsensical approach you are happy to no
longer have to sit through inaccuracies
to decipher truths but now there are no
truths at all all that you are given are
absurdities she speaks in a way that
makes you scratch your head one saying
for no apparent reason I take a hammer
and I break my legs I break them for the
better after so many scratches you swear
you've dug an inch into your skin and so
you move on to
scp-2085-a-4 hoping for better luck she
is straightforward with you that much
you like but she's hostile and doesn't
cooperate when you ask her her name she
raises her middle finger she tucks it
back in to create a fist and then that
fist punches the divider between you no
amount of reinforced glass could make
you feel safe at that moment cracks
spread it looks like a web spun by a
spider and you feel as small as one
thankfully a protective shutter is
lowered aerosol sedatives are pumped
into the containment unit she continues
to try to escape yelling profanities
even harsh for someone locked behind
bars your ears have taken a beating from
curse words nonsensical Rambles and
heaps of misinformation you want to
lower your head into a toilet bowl and
hear nothing but water yes that is where
these women have driven you your head to
the bottom of a toilet bowl you have put
in so many hours and yet you have
learned nothing new and if you can't
learn anything new you might have to
rely more on what you already know but
what do you know well you know this
their track record is quite impressive
verified operations include smuggling
theft assault vandalism kidnapping
extortion property damage possession of
fissile materials corporate sabotage
embezzlement identity theft fraud
copyright infringement piracy session
transport and sale of anomalous items
and of course tax evasion yet when
grilled under the heat of Investigation
they do not reveal any details about the
nature of these operations you just know
that they happened all that is told is
that scp-2085 navigates in such a way as
to minimize the chance of Civilian
casualties and maximize material and
morale damage to their target they are
proud of this it seems as if scp-2085
perceives themselves on the side of good
while their list of operations on paper
look like crimes they stand proudly
behind them pleading guilty with a grin
but behind every smile is more teeth
teeth that go beyond saying cheese teeth
hiding in the dark caves of a sealed
mouth and you are determined to play
dentist and find your way in but
scp-2085 doesn't say ah for just anyone
so how are you to to understand a group
that resists our preferred methods of
learning how are you to properly assess
the pieces of a puzzle when the puzzle
is glued tightly together it starts at
the top before you can decipher the
motives of a Nation you'd be smart to
study their leader and if you want to
extrapolate the schemes of a football
team you'd interview the coach and to
truly know the moral of a television
show you'd be better off asking the
Creator than the actors all of this is
just to say if you are to ever
understand the complexities of scp-2085
it is necessary you begin with
scp-2085-b the person pulling the string
of the entire operation for all of these
years now you might be imagining a man
of many muscles someone able to fight a
bear with an arm tied behind his back
someone who kicks through saloon doors
tilts back his liquor and walks out with
a woman in each arm or cat girl but
you'd be dead wrong
scp-2085-b also known as wizard does not
look like an imposing lead at first
glance or even at the hundredth glance
he is generally in very poor health and
his face shows it he suffers from a
variety of illnesses most notably a
vitamin D deficiency acute radiation
syndrome and as unmanageable scarring
from severe and repeated skin ulceration
he doesn't wear a cape and glamorous
spandex often found hanging in
superheroes closets but instead he wears
an advanced crew escape suit accompanied
by a cheap bathrobe and flimsy red felt
wizard's hat he looks with no elegant
way of putting it like a dork a goofball
a doofus
you get the point furthermore he is an
adult male human with certain cybernetic
and genetic enhancements he has an
adaptation of the gastrointestinal tract
to allow for an all-liquid diet within
his suit an esophageal input port and
waste output Port are integrated it is
equipped with modifications to regulate
sweat reduce abrasion damage from
extended usage and Aid in skin
regeneration his genetic enhancements
include the replacement of 11 previously
missing digits on hands and feet and
also has an internal drug pump typically
used for painkillers because as we are
about to learn
scp-2085-b is most often on the wrong
end of pain notice these modifications
are not those you would find in a
science fiction novel but more likely
behind the trench coat of a suspicious
man in a dark alley and we all know
nothing good is ever concealed behind a
trench coat but have you ever wondered
if that truth also extends to Rogues
because when we pull open
scp-2085s what we find is truly
terrifying
scp-2085-1 scp-2085-1
1 is a fibrous mass of self-replicating
carbon nanomaterials within
scp-2085-b's chest cavity with growths
protruding into the liver pancreas
gallbladder spinal cord and left lung
the growth of the scp-2085-1 and its
consumption of
scp-2085-b's body tissues has been
impeded through the addition of various
containment implants used to sever
communication between growth sections
and control nodes and counter the
replication process
scp-2085-1's rate of replication without
the influence of these containment
implants is unknown
scp-2085-1's periods of activity occur
on average once every three months the
process lasts for up to 15 minutes and
causes
scp-2085-b intense pain imagine a heart
attack imagine Mike Tyson using your
sternum like a punching bag imagine a
cactus strapped to your front this is
the pain and torture
scp-2085 wears daily there is no S logo
printed on his chest like Superman no
symmetrically slick symbol like Batman
instead just cancerous growth Kryptonite
worn like a tie the knot never to be
loosened but to
scp-2085-b this anomaly is not just a
number to be studied but more so a being
to be understood it is more personal
than a medical condition it is something
that he wakes up with each and every day
he calls it red at first the foundation
saw
scp-2085's close connection with red to
be childish and silly as if a small boy
who names his freckles out of boredom
and loneliness but as you are about to
see how they met was more memorable than
first finding a freckle in the mirror a
meteor struck down and
scp-2085-b was the only person at the
scene red was inside as wizard
approached the meteor red leapt onto him
and buried a home into his chest cavity
far from a freckle on the skin red is a
cancer it grows and grows leeching to
what it can it can't be removed with
surgery it can't be covered by a
Band-Aid it has no empathy or Mercy it
leeches on and eats away at its host but
it's more than pain that it causes
falling off a swing set and bursting
open your leg hurts sure but at least
both you and your injury are on the same
team Cuts try to heal when left alone
injuries make effort to find homeostasis
but red is a different breed it hates us
in a way that injuries are incapable of
doing it has a deep disdain for Humanity
it tears wizard down reveling in his
degradation its sole purpose is to eat
him whole wizard can only take this
personally as he doesn't just feel the
universally understood sensation of pain
but also the unique passion of its
purpose
scp-2085-b's adventures with red seem to
be where our Story begins and what
ultimately keeps it moving in fact it
was while
scp-2085-b was running around trying to
fix his chest with implants when he
eventually met who we refer to as
scp-2085-a-1 through 8-5 he was at the
clinic to get some new parts and when he
was going through the installation
process there was an explosion one of
the five girls barched out of a building
guns blazing he started running
alongside them with his chest half open
the woman embraced him immediately and
reciprocated knowing nothing of the
situation he instinctively knew to take
their side there were bullets coming
from both directions but he intuitively
understood which side was good and which
side was bad a distinction scp-2085
believes the world needs help clarify
but it is hard to see a reason for a war
when our eyes are focused on the
casualties beliefs are less clear when
tucked behind bullets the sounds of
gunfire muffled their message morality
while a complex subject
scp-2085 believes is simplified by the
masses events are deemed good or bad
based on the term used for them in a
court of law when we see the words
smuggling theft assault vandalism
corporate sabotage embezzlement identity
theft fraud copyright infringement
piracy and of course tax evasion it is
our impulse to label those as morally
bad but scp-2085 desperately wants you
to look Beyond The Language they want
the words to dissipate off the paper
letter by letter until all you have is a
blank page now look at the pencil and
the hand that holds it watch how it
moves that is what matters whether it
draws weapons or mermaids is relevant
both can be used for good both can be
used for evil intent is everything and
scp-2085 intends on making the world a
better place or so they like to claim
but maybe there is more to it after
scp-2085-b and the five women escape the
gunfire they went on to steal a boat and
hightail it out of Japan they spent
their nights out there on the ocean
stargazing and stuffing themselves with
instant Ramen and cheap beer and
surprisingly between all the crazy
Adventures as
cp2085-b had been on this is what
Wizards spoke about most the time spent
on the boat out at sea for the first
time in ages he was finally somewhere
where he was happy it was this moment
that actually meant the most to him it
wasn't the children they apparently
saved from imperialism it wasn't the
wealth they apparently redistributed to
the poor it wasn't any good deed at all
it was the selfish almost shallow
sensation of being happy on a boat this
singular moment meant so much to
scp-2085-b he reflected on it as if it
were a wedding day or a memorable
vacation which makes you wonder
scp-2085 has been investigated and
interrogated and all that they preach is
that they are doing the world a favor
with their Antics their tails are
captivating sure but is it actually
storytelling or is it just virtue
signaling there is an emotional depth to
scp-2085 Unique to any other militant
Anarchist group while they are
genetically designed to most efficiently
complete missions they're not all robots
fixed on the high of task completion
each and every one of them wants more
they want to grow they want a group not
just to have the numbers to overthrow a
government but to have the numbers to
fill a room or boat with companionship
when they refuse to cooperate with you
and leak information about their
operation maybe what you are witnessing
isn't the strength of their loyalty but
also the weakness of their codependence
and so you decide this is the new angle
you're going to take with your
interrogation you enter the room with a
new Focus you feel like an earthquake
eager to make cracks in their core you
isolate
scp-2085-a-4 you're met expectantly with
hostility you fight back with psychology
you cross your legs and put on your
glasses as if to say let's talk about
that anger where does it stem from she
strengthens her emotional guard but you
keep prying you say that it sounds like
she is lonely you say it sounds like her
loyalty doesn't come from good character
but rather insecurity and self-doubt you
ask her if completing missions with her
crew was actually a way to improve the
world or was it just an elaborate way to
build a close friend group bound
together by Common goals did New
Missions Sprout from necessity or were
they fabricated by my fears of being
alone with nothing to do were end of
operation high fives to celebrate good
overcoming evil or were they just
excuses to feel the touch of another
human skin to skin you stop there and
let silence do the rest
scp-2085-a-4 sits with her thoughts she
is ready to break and finally she does
she says she's willing to provide video
logs of the group's former operations
she's ready to cooperate she's ready to
abandon loyalty to groupthink and focus
instead on self-improvement in exchange
she kindly asks that she be reciprocated
and that the sanction placed on her be
lifted you come to an agreement and with
that you feel like your work is done but
is it you're feeling cocky and
accomplished you forward the video logs
to an isolated Network for d-class
personnel to review and you sit back and
enjoy a celebratory drink you have
infiltrated and broken the mind of a
genetically modified radical design for
Anarchy you give yourself a pat on the
back and you're feeling so great that
the pat might even turn into a massage
but before you can indulge in that deep
tissue level of self-admiration the
phone rings can it be a call from the
President telling you that you're the
greatest investigator of all time can it
be that they need you to pose in front
of a world-renowned artist so they can
erect a statue of you in the center of
town square but the Panic on the other
side of the phone halts your Daydream
your stomach drops as if a sudden
plummet from a perfectly vertical roller
coaster you have fallen into a trap the
video log at the center of your
negotiation was not all it was promised
to be the file titled backup.avi
consisted of a two hour long video of a
feces filled toilet presumably recorded
from
scp-2085-a's point of view accompanied
by an audio Loop of the folk song
korobaniki as performed by the Red Army
Choir its absurdity feels like an art
project like a short film you are
assigned to watch in a community college
class but instead of putting you to
sleep it does a whole lot more the
contained audio visual Cognito Hazard
induced anaphylaxis and exudative
diarrhea in the observing d-class
subject the d-class subject died four
minutes after initial access of the file
from blood loss and oxygen deprivation
scp-2085-a-4 sits in containment
laughing while you sit there on your
couch dethroned back where you started
having thought you tore scp-2085 apart
with your mind only to learn that your
efforts only reinforced it with more
glue throwing indestructible lizards
into Vats of acid hunting strange
chicken men through forests in Ireland
arguing in Latin with a man wearing a
haunted Roman centurion's helmet when
you join the SCP Foundation you might be
expecting high octane drama of the time
especially with the name street sweepers
you'd expect this mobile task force to
be neck deep in some real action-packed
street racing maybe you wouldn't think
that they'd be tasked with driving all
day every day in four hour shifts
tailing A semi-truck all over Birmingham
Alabama but as agent Moore and his
colleague pulled into the lay-by behind
the truck neither of them were ready for
what they were about to witness
scp-2590 was first discovered by the
foundation at a routine traffic stop
investigating a totally different
anomaly in the Birmingham area agents
Peters and Smith had been posing as
local police officers the foundation had
been trying to track down an artifact
that was supposedly being smuggled
across the U.S in the back of a
nondescript station wagon Peterson Smith
had been allocated a pair of beat-up old
police cruisers which they'd parked
across the dirt road fully blocking any
traffic from coming through it was
several hours into their shift when the
incident occurred just at the point they
were starting to lose focus taking a
look through the suitcases in
memorabilia from a family's trip to
Disney World Peters had taken way too
long to hear the noise of the engine
swelling behind him he spun around to
see the hulking shape of the semi-truck
barreling straight towards him agent
Smith and a family of five with only two
seconds to react he yelled out at the
top of his lungs and dived out of the
way leaving the trunk of the car wide
open with five screams emerging from
inside Smith who had been sitting in one
of the Cruisers only just managed to get
out before the semi made contact eyes
closed agent Peters waited for the
inevitable sound of screaming rubber the
bang of metal on metal shower of Glass
on asphalt but it never came when he
opened his eyes the station wagon was
still parked up in front of them the two
police crews are still blocking the road
and all the Disney merch still piled
high in the trunk the semi was driving
off along the road on the other side of
their blockade with not a scratch on it
without a moment's hesitation agent
Smith who had kept his eyes open and
witnessed the whole thing leapt into
action he ordered his partner still
lying confused in the dirt to administer
Class A and nestics to the family and
call in for backup agent Smith himself
jammed his keys into the ignition
twisting them so hard he almost bent the
metal and took off after the vehicle
what agent Smith and Peters had just
witnessed was the very first Foundation
exposure to
scp-2590 fondly nicknamed trailer trash
as Smith pulled up alongside the vehicle
and studied it for the first time he
made a note of its initial appearance
over the radio an appearance which
remains changed years later the badges
on the vehicle claim that it is an
International ProStar day cab
semi-trailer truck complete with an
unmarked trailer as the agent flicked on
his lights and indicated that the
vehicle should pull over he noted that
it didn't have any license plates on it
either front or rear he leaned forward
in his seat trying to peer into the cab
to make out the driver but in the
Alabama Sun the man just looked like a
shadowy figure they drove side by side
along the road for almost a mile the
truck made no signs of pulling over
despite agent Smith's continued
insistence and repeated flashes of the
cop lights but it also didn't attempt to
pull away either it just continued to
drive a few miles per hour below the
speed limit the driver didn't seem to
look across at him once having discussed
it with Foundation staff they decided it
was best not to draw attention to the
situation they had no idea whether this
SCP was hostile or posed any threat to
civilian life but having blue and red
lights flashing at it appeared to be
doing little to change the situation
instead he switched off the sirens and
pulled in behind the truck tailing it
around Birmingham as the foundation
readied for their agents to respond to
the situation for almost an hour nothing
of note happened agent Smith drove
behind the trailer watching it like a
hawk he observed that it obeyed every
traffic law to a t it never broke the
speed limit never cut anyone off and
left room for other vehicles to merge if
it hadn't seen it drive straight through
a roadblock as if it wasn't there he
would have never suspected a thing but
then the truck turned its turn signal on
they had just come off the highway and
merged onto a quiet side street just as
the sun was starting to hang low in the
sky the truck crept across the side of
the road squeezing its brakes gently and
stopped agent Smith matched the action
the whole way pulling up about 20 feet
behind the trailer in constant radio
communication he kicked open his door
and stepped out into to the evening air
Foundation Personnel advised that he
keep his hand on his gun at all times
and approach with caution he didn't
really need them to tell him that Smith
called for the driver to step out of the
cab no response the truck just sat there
with its hazards on engine off after a
moment there was a clunk and the trailer
door started to slowly open all by
itself agent Smith called in backup but
there were still several minutes out
instead he ran back to the car gun
raised and waited to see what was inside
as the doors slowly opened to reveal
nothing no not quite nothing there was
something small on the floor of the
trailer right in the center as if it
hadn't been moved around at all by the
vehicle's motion it was red a kind of
elongated cuboid he reported it all to
the foundation over his radio then
paused when he recognized what it was a
KitKat candy bar or to be more specific
a Kit Kat chunky what happened after
this point was hazy agent Smith was
found on the roadside just 20 minutes
later confused about what had happened
the truck was nowhere in sight however a
security camera from a convenience store
just up the street happened to capture
the interaction in the footage you see
agent Smith approaching the trailer with
his gun raised looking at the KitKat he
tries to enter the trailer but is unable
to so he approaches the driver's side
door while talking to the shadowy figure
in the cab he drops his gun and stands
motionless a confused and sleepy
expression on his face until the trailer
door closes and the SCP drives away
contact was re-established with
scp-2590 soon after and has been
maintained almost uninterrupted ever
since the findings made on that initial
encounter seem to hold true across
further examination Personnel have
reached out to Navistar International
the company that supposedly manufactures
this model of semi-truck but there
appears to be no records of its creation
or shipment to the US in fact no
documentary education at all can be
attributed to the truck or any
components on it the driver in the front
cab is a humanoid figure who is
perpetually shrouded in Shadow
designated
scp-2590-1 attempts to reveal the
driver's figures have proved ineffective
as even powerful spotlights do not shed
enough light into the cab to render the
driver visible quite what this driver's
role is in the operation of scp-2590 is
unknown
scp-2590-1 appears to have some
proximity-based amnestic qualities as
anyone approaching it on foot has
reported memory loss and confusion soon
after just like agent Smith as also
discovered by the two agents and their
roadblock containment of this SCP is
simply not possible while the majority
of the time the SCP is corporeal it
possesses the ability to pass through
solid objects at will all attempted
roadblocks have resulted in the same
thing happening the SCP will just phase
right through on them as if nothing was
there since it cannot be contained in
the usual way a different operation has
been set up to monitor the truck's
activities which so far have proven to
be apparently harmless to the civilian
population mobile task force gamma 133
also known as the street sweepers has
been established to follow this SCP
around Birmingham at all times they
operate in four hour shifts with two
agents in unmarked Vehicles sticking
close behind the trailer at all times
the foundation was able to fit a
tracking device onto it as well
providing researchers with continuous
location data for where they can find
the vehicle at seemingly random times
supposedly determined by the SCP itself
it pulls over somewhere quiet and opens
the door to its trailer the door will
remain open for 60 seconds and then
close again any attempts to enter the
trailer have been blocked by some kind
of invisible barrier seemingly
impenetrable to most approaches more
violent and destructive methods of Entry
cannot be authorized for testing due to
the heavy civilian population in the
surrounding area every time the doors
open there is something different in the
trailer researchers are trying to
ascertain some kind of pattern or
messaging behind most of the objects but
many seem to be random the current list
of things that have appeared in the back
of scp-2590 include an iPhone 3G a red
apple and a lit light bulb without any
visible form of power supply most
notable about the objects in the trailer
is that often they appear to be human
beings as happened on the knife that
agent Moore was on duty in the street
sweepers the agents pulled in behind the
truck as per usual when it slowed to a
stop beside the highway agent Moore got
out of the vehicle second unenthused
about the monotony of the task he had
been assigned expecting to see a
cardboard box or a ChapStick when the
trailer door opened he was left shocked
when he came face to face with himself
few people can say they have seen
themselves in real life most of them
have been administered with various
amnestics to make them forget but agent
Moore went on to report how bizarre of
an experience it was he claimed that it
was utterly unlike looking in a mirror
where your reflection is flipped and
follows your every move seeing yourself
standing in three dimensions moving
independently and evidently in a great
deal of distress is an experience that
few would envy anytime a human being
materializes in the trailer they appear
to be in a great deal of distress as
they attempt to escape through the
invisible barrier agent Moore and his
partner agent Hall could do nothing but
stand and watch in confusion as the copy
of him attempted to free himself before
after the usual 60 seconds the trailer
door closed and the vehicle pulled away
again several instances have occurred of
duplicate humans appearing in the
trailer but each time the original
person seems to have had no knowledge of
this taking place and nothing out of the
ordinary happens to them however there
appears to be some small pattern
demonstrating the SCP as an awareness of
the foundation as it has also duplicated
agent inglis's sister who has no
connection to this SCP at all incident
16 was the most distressing of all as a
large slab of metal appeared in the back
of the trailer with the SCP Foundation
logo painted across it agent Inglis and
Schultz were on duty at this time and
observed copious amounts of blood
flowing out of the metal slab before
long the blood filled the back of the
trailer pushing up against the invisible
barrier all of a sudden 52 seconds into
the encounter the barrier vanished and a
Cascade of blood with the slab inside
were launched out of the two agents at a
speed of over 190 kilometers an hour
killing them both instantly since this
incident
scp-2590 has been treated with greater
caution the most mysterious thing to
have come from researching this truck
came on December 4th 2011 when for the
first time the truck trucks tracking
Beacon stopped working it had been seen
pulling into an abandoned warehouse and
so a team of street sweepers was
immediately dispatched to investigate
when they arrived they found the vehicle
moving through the warehouse at a slow
crawl choosing to pursue on foot and
leave a pair of agents at the entrance
they followed the SCP through the
facility until it came to what agents
described as a service tunnel or sewer
of some sort putting headlamps on they
followed the truck down into the tunnel
maintaining radio contact throughout as
they reported the direction they were
traveling and the distance it quickly
became apparent to Foundation Personnel
that this was no ordinary tunnel the
warehouse was positioned overlooking a
cliff and so the geography was not
physically possible as the street
sweepers descended further into the
tunnel they noted there was increased
levels of carbon monoxide radio contacts
started to dip in and out losing signal
as they went further downhill just at
the edge of their signal with the
foundation the trucks stopped and opened
its trailer door inside was just a
single piece of parchment with the words
I'm just delivering a message written on
it after the usual 60 seconds the
trailer door closed and the truck
continued after they had passed the
kilometer Mark the radio signal worsened
quickly and after a couple of scrambled
messages the team down there were not
heard from again the channel stayed open
for another six hours before the
foundation made the decision to announce
the agents missing in action in March
2015 over three years later a radio
signal came into contact with the
foundation again from Birmingham Alabama
it was from the headset of the squad
leader who had gone into the tunnel
initially confused as to who had gained
access to the cons channel the
foundation demanded that the agent State
his full name and rank the agent himself
confused obliged questioning why they
were so suspicious he and his team
claimed to have only lost contact for
about 15 minutes they had followed the
FCP a little further until carbon
monoxide levels had risen too high to
continue at which point they had watched
the truck disappearing into the distance
as they walked back to the surface all
agents have undergone extensive
psychological Rehabilitation to settle
them back into society as well as
classes to fill them in on things like
the London Olympics the Ice Bucket
Challenge and Gangnam Style as for
scp-2590 it is back out on the roads
roaming around Birmingham Alabama
continuously never stopping for fuel
always obeying the rules of the road
occasionally opening its trailer doors
to reveal new and bizarre findings
everybody remembered where they were
what they had been doing when the SCP
Foundation revealed themselves to the
world it was an event that had so
fundamentally changed the lives of every
person on Earth that it became pretty
hard to forget that momentous horrible
day even though for most people it had
begun as a day like most others Dane
Moss had been at home when it started
his roommates were talking about buying
an air hockey table for their place
something to liven up their Saturday
nights even as he half listened to them
discussing it Dane figured it would
never happen he was right of course but
he never could have anticipated the
thing that stopped it all of them had
stopped and Fallen silent as the news
report came through a group calling
themselves the SCP Foundation previously
responsible for the containment of
anomalous objects entities and phenomena
had declared its new intention to
exterminate the entire human race Dane
Split Second belief that the broadcast
was a Cloverfield style viral marketing
stunt for a new movie was quickly
disproved when the ground started to
shake unbeknownst to him the foundation
was not only real but a detonated
nuclear charges along the back of
scp-169 an enormous ancient arthropod
thats body had made up in archipelago
adrift in the ocean the detonation
caused the Leviathan to stir resulting
in massive earthquakes and tsunamis Dane
was the only one to make it out of the
apartment alive elsewhere Joe Reese had
been grabbing a coffee on his way home
from work he briefly overheard the news
report but barely paid it to any mind
then waiting for his flat white
wondering what the holdup was he caught
a part of a conversation between two
people behind him what is that thing one
asked I don't know but its face is pure
nightmare fuel the other replied a bunch
of pictures of it just appeared on
everyone's socials it's really freaky
stuff a sudden shriek went out from a
number of the coffee shop patrons Joe
noticed a towering humanoid Shadow being
cast by something behind him its arms
were stretched out disproportionately
long and it was attacking the two people
behind him acting on an instantaneous
fight or flight response Joe ran without
looking back to see scp-096 slaughtering
everyone that had seen its face
around the same time as the foundation's
ominous announcement was played over
every news channel on the planet Renee
Hudson and Skye Soto had been on a date
the pair of them had been enjoying
hanging out playing a few mildly
competitive games at the bowling alley
but there was still something unspoken
lingering in the air neither sky nor
Renee really felt any connection they
liked each other's company but that was
as far as it went although neither one
of them knew how to broach the subject
for fear of hurting the other's feelings
and in the same vein neither of them
could have predicted the commotion that
would happen next the noise came from
outside the deafening screams followed
by a flood of people running for their
lives hundreds if not thousands were
fleeing any that fell over in the street
being trampled underfoot by everyone
behind them human beings move like a
mass of ants clambering over each other
to get away from a gigantic ferocious
lizard despite the news broadcast
declaring themselves and intentions to
wipe out all of humanity nobody on the
ground would ever be able to comprehend
just why the foundation Unleashed
scp-682 had allowed the heart to destroy
reptile to slaughter innocent civilians
in drones while they didn't know it or
may not have agreed Skye Renee Dane and
Joe were all lucky to have survived the
initial anomalous Onslaught Unleashed by
a rogue SCP Foundation it did little to
ease the pain of being displaced from
their homes forced to migrate across the
country to join camps of other survivors
made refugees by anomaly attacks and the
efforts of apathetic agents of the
foundation and of the four of them not
one could have predicted the shared fate
that awaited them during the months in
the wake of the foundation's opening
assault on mankind Renee and Skye had
mostly stuck together they had moved
further and further south managing to
stay safe neither one had thought about
their awkward date in months they were
just grateful to have someone they knew
to stick together with meanwhile Joe and
Dane were hopping from one refugee camp
to the next much in the same way moving
North and Eastward respectively after
deploying their first wave of anomalies
the SCP foundation's efforts had shifted
to primarily focusing on groups of
interests that could pose a threat to
their plans while organizations with
knowledge of the anomalous like the
global occult Coalition were among the
first in their crosshairs the civilian
population was left living in fear but
unscathed that is until the foundation
began targeting the refugee camps one of
their tactics was to unleash
scp-2241 a seven-year-old boy with
reality warping Powers into Survivor
communities to act as a living weapon
destroying the larger refugee camps it
was the increased frequency and
ruthlessness of the foundation's attacks
on human survivors that forced Skye
Renee Dane and Joe to a knowingly
converge on each other camps for
survivors started getting smaller
consisting of only a handful of people
in the hopes that this would make it
easier for them to avoid detection by
the foundation arriving and hopping off
the back of a Jeep with only the clothes
on their backs the four strangers
exchanged uncertain glances they had
been brought to an abandoned dock the
wreckage of an overturned cargo ship
laying on its side in the harbor
shipping containers were scattered all
around looking as if they had Spilled
Out of the boat and onto the dock the
driver of the Jeep hadn't told them
where to go from there instead he had
just driven off without so much as a
word the four of them looked around Dane
seemed particularly unnerved at being so
close to the water despite it having
been months since the Leviathan settled
back to sleep suddenly one of the
shipping containers burst open and a
broad flannel shirt wearing man stepped
out his face was buried beneath a thick
beard a shotgun resting against his
shoulder as he approached the group The
Man Stern Stony expression quickly
changed into a wide grin as he drovely
and unexpected pulled Dane into a hug
welcome my friends
the man roared with laughter Oh welcome
uh who are you Skye asked ah of course
allow me to introduce myself he
responded letting go of Dane who needed
to catch his breath after being squeezed
so much my name is joviannis for safety
I watch over this Camp the man announced
Camp Joe asked looking at the wreckage
the foundation has been getting more
zealous with targeting those of us that
are left joviannis explained gesturing
for the four to follow him as he walked
back towards the container so we had to
take a less conspicuous approach to
surviving splitting the camps up into
fewer people dispersing everyone around
a bit more end of of course he swung
open the door to the metal container
inside the cramped space there were two
bunks either side one above the other
making four in total along with a
sleeping bag on the floor stand in place
is the foundation one thing to look
jovianis continued we have to sleep in
here Renee asked in disbelief better for
avoid in detection the Camp's protector
replied otherwise the next Camp along is
only 20 minutes away on foot over in a
warehouse if you'd rather go there but
be warned they have rats although it
came with a brief adjustment period the
group quickly acclimatized to living in
the abandoned dock each of them came to
appreciate jovannis's efforts to keep
them all fed with what few rations they
had the four of them started calling him
Big Joe referring to Joe as Lil Joe to
avoid confusion of the group Dane seemed
to have the hardest time adapting he was
something of a conspiracy theorist
anxiously talking about the other great
disasters throughout human history and
wondering if the foundation had been
responsible for them all Skye felt a
little sorry for him so they decided to
humor his theory that the eruption of
Mount Vesuvius in Pompeii was also the
SCP foundation's doing despite occurring
all the way back in 79 A.D through all
their various concerns about surviving
in this anomalous apocalyptic world Big
Joe seemed to have a talent for keeping
the group's spirits up whether it was by
recounting them all with folk stories or
turning bland food rations into more
flavorful meals he made the four of them
feel safe especially with his weapon
never far away that is until one evening
a glowing red streak shot through the
air not far from Camp catching
jovianis's immediate attention it was an
emergency flare set up by the
neighboring camp at the warehouse
something was wrong grabbing a shotgun
and urging Sky Dane Renee and Lil Joe to
stay put Big Joe left running off into
the growing dark of the night to try to
help the whole group stayed awake
waiting for their protector to return
the next hour feeling like an eternity
by the time he returned the sun had
fully set outside even by the low light
of their lamps inside the container it
was clear by his face that any and all
optimism had drained out of jovianis
there was nothing left of all there was
nothing left all of them were gone he
explained unable to believe what he had
seen or was this oil everywhere roasted
like an acid just burning through what
was left of them trying to regain some
semblance of composure he urged the
group to get some sleep reassuring them
that they would be safe for the rest of
the night not one of them realized just
how wrong they were or that they'd never
seen jovianis again after they fell
asleep Renee was the first to discover
he had gone missing screaming with panic
waking up sky and the two boys after
they had calmed down Skye tried to
rationalize what was going on they were
worried about Big Joe and the others but
he couldn't afford to lose their nerve
and potentially attract the attention of
a foundation kill Squad and it's the
foundation Dane babbled terrified they
found us they're closing in oh man relax
Sky replied all of you chill there are
other camps nearby maybe Big Joe went to
check on them too see if what had
happened to the warehouse group happened
anywhere
you don't think he would have told us
well Joe retorted seeming to be the
least concerned about joviannis's
whereabouts we were asleep it's not like
him to wake us up he knows we'd worry
Skye answered what if he's dead Renee
sobbed don't say that they replied she's
right though he left his shotgun right
here Joe interjected again whatever got
the warehouse group killed him it's
obvious at least I don't have to go by
that stupid nickname anymore what the
hell man Danielle you're joking at a
time like this what's wrong with you
there was an uncomfortably long pause
everyone in the container turned to look
at Joe leaning against one of the metal
walls with his arms folded the other
three were all thinking the same thing
although Dane was the first to say it
aloud you killed him didn't you don't be
ridiculous Joe chastised him backing
away slightly betraying his own little
hint of fear you and Renee are
hysterical you both need to calm down
before Joe could finish his sentence a
withered arm reached out of the wall and
grabbed his throat it looked like the
rotting decaying arm of a corpse
protruding out of a puddle of black
mucus that now seemed to be spreading
across the inner wall of the container
Renee screamed in horror as more of the
black substance Ooze from the arm
melting Away Joe as it held him
helplessly in its grip it was then that
a face peered through the oily patch
smeared on the wall the night nourished
Visage of
scp-106 the old man for a second Skye
thought about trying to help Joe they
could have pulled him free but it was
already too late the corrosion was
spreading it looked like it would melt
them too if they so much just touched it
Joe was gone the remaining three of them
burst out of the shipping container they
had called Home afraid for their lives
what the hell was that Dane screamed oh
man I knew it they've sent a monster
after us Skye barely paid him any mind
their attention grabbed by movement
nearby someone had started running the
second they had exited the shipping
crate they had been watching from a
distance hey hey up this guy yelled
about to run after them Skye Renee's
voice was cracking under the weight of
her Terror turning around they saw it
the old man stood behind Renee it looked
even more grotesque under the low light
provided by several distant fires in the
ruins of cities the foundation had
destroyed given the Horizon a hellish
glow
scp-106's withered lipless face bore his
rotting teeth locked in a skull-like
grin he'd give a sense he was gaining
some Twisted enjoyment out of what he
did next Renee had been frozen to the
spot sniffling in fear her legs rigid
and locked in place until the old man
claimed to hand over her shoulder then
she cried out in a blood-curdling shriek
of Agony more of the black ooze spilled
from his emaciated fingers dripping down
her front while Skye looked on in Terror
Renee had been the one person who had
been with them the entire time from the
moment the foundation Unleashed hell
every Camp they moved to Renee was in
the same one with them the pair of them
may have not been a couple but she had
been the only constant in this anomalous
apocalypse and now this Sinister SCP was
killing her fighting every urge to grab
Renee and pull her free Sky instead let
themselves be led Away by Dame choking
back tears they ran alongside him in the
direction of whoever had been watching
them the shadowy figure was just about
visible although definitely still close
enough to be heard in the dark there was
the sound of a fall accompanied by a
pained grunt indicating that whoever had
been watching the container had tripped
both Dane and Skye knew that this was
their chance together they lunged at the
figure before he had a chance to
scramble back to his feet with Dane
pinning The Observer down by his wrists
that was when the light of the burning
City on the horizon illuminated his face
he was the Jeep driver the one who had
dropped them at jovianus's Camp to begin
with the only other person apart from
Big Joe who knew where their Camp was
you Sky declared what were you doing
spying on us I have nothing to say to
you the man's man answer their question
Danielle slapping the man in the face
although he didn't seem to react what is
this thing chasing us why did they kill
our friends you might as well tell us
this guy told him calmly after all once
that monster catches up we'll all be
dead you were watching expecting a
result right how to make sure none of us
made it not that there's anyone left for
us to tell if we did survive he's with
the foundation Dane gas catching on
quickly you had them send that corpse
thing to kill us man
scp-106 the undercover MTF age
incorrected and yeah it's here because
we sent it you all went underground
hiding in your little camps where you
had to look even closer to find you all
ungrateful all of you ungrateful Sky
exploded and raged and offended at the
idea anyone could justify all the Death
the foundation had Unleashed on the
world what do you expect us to thank you
for hunting your fellow human beings to
Extinction dropping nightmare after
Nightmare on us and we're meant to be
grateful for that none of you understand
what we're trying to do the foundation
agent replied without a hint of remorse
what we're trying to do is bigger more
important than your mundane Little Lives
the only way we can save Humanity from
It Is by wiping you out before either
sky or Dane could ask what it was a
gloopy oily smear appeared on the ground
clawing his way out of it the old man
reached for the MTF operative
disintegrating him like he had done
before but the agent barely reacted
didn't cry out like Renee or Joe had he
was still even as he was being melted by
the slimy black secretion of scp-106 it
was as if the man couldn't feel the pain
of what was happening to him as he died
a splatter of the same corrosive mucus
spread onto Dane's sleeve freaking out
as it began burning through his jacket
he desperately tried to wipe it off only
to smear it spreading the dissolving
substance further and crying out as he
felt eating into the palms of his hands
scp-106 climbed out of its oily puddle
dropping the disintegrating MTF agent he
disappeared into the corrosive pool
Vanishing from Scythe like he'd fallen
into a ditch Skye backed away their eyes
locked with the sunken stare of the old
man feeling their legs begin to freeze
in fear just like Renee's
gun Dane rast laying at scp-106's feet
slowly succumbing to the same fate that
I'd befallen the others big big Joe's
gun he rasped again with the last of his
strength he used his arm to grab the old
man's ankle howling in pain as more of
the black substance oozed from the
monster's wrinkled flesh Sky turned and
raced back towards the shipping
container hardly daring to look over
their shoulder every movement every tiny
shift of Shadow they detected in the
corner of their eye filled their mind
with the images of the old man bearing
down on them wearing that sadistic
skeletal grin Sky pulled the heavy metal
door open using all their strength to
get back inside their arms were numbed
trembling so much with Terror that it
was like they weren't attached properly
they fumbled about in the dark their
fingers brushing up against the weapon
resting in the corner where jovianis had
left it pulling on the pump Sky turned
the gun raised knowing that the old man
was right behind them and pulled the
trigger it gave a redundant click it was
empty no ammunition the gun had been
just for show
scp-106 reached for the weapon and
pulled it from Skye's hands the metal of
it slowly melting as it was coated in
the tar-like corrosive substance
recoiling their hands from it Skye went
to dash for the door only to feel the
old man's bony burning fingers hook into
their back and drag them towards the
greasy black stain he was leaning out of
pulling them into his domain this world
had been a living nightmare since the
foundation had revealed itself and
Unleashed an anomalous apocalypse upon
Humanity but
scp-106's pocket Dimension might just
have been worse welcome back dear
viewers of SCP explained we hope you've
been keeping well and we also hope that
your health insurance covers blown Minds
because today we're using our trademark
anomatron 6000 to pit an anomalous
Legend against another Marvel Legend
that's right it's scp-682 versus Dr
Michael morbius of the 2022 cinematic
Masterpiece morbius of course there is
one issue that we should share with you
before we begin we haven't actually seen
morbius however here's the wonderful
thing statistically you haven't either
in fact we tried to get the animatron
6000 to process morbius as raw data for
the simulation but our antivirus
software kept stopping it intriguing so
instead we simply hit randomized traits
on the animatron so it's free to use
Advanced AI could conceive what morbius
is like and what his abilities probably
are and as far as you or I know it might
even be correct so let's get this show
on the the road and see if the hard to
destroy reptile could hone against its
own at Cinema's most tragically memed
upon superhero prepare for perhaps the
most absurd and ridiculous video with
the exception of the Among Us video that
we've ever released on here in other
words it's morbin time it began as many
bizarre SCP Foundation stories do with
scp-682 cracking the glass of its acid
tank and preparing to spill chaos and
Terror onto site 19. for most people
even seeing actual footage of this would
be a life-defining traumatic incident
for most season Foundation researchers
it was just another Sunday when 682
busted through the nearest wall like a
psychopathic reptilian Kool-Aid man
while guards engaged in the futile task
of trying to subdue it with small arms
fire the senior researchers languidly
made their way to the nearest secure
Panic Room and hunkered down as was
standard protocol for scp-682 escapes
all available mobile task force units
would be dispatched single mindedly
focused on cutting the lizard back down
to size but the problem was this wasn't
just any other Sunday it was Super Bowl
Sunday and seeing as most mobile task
force operatives are incredibly tough
and manly they generally love football
and promise they definitely come and
take down 682 as soon as the game was
over this would be one thing if scp-682
was content to just terrorize the usual
denizens of Psych 19 today but no it'd
been a while since the hard to destroy
reptile had tasted civilian flesh and he
intended to rectify that toot sweet in a
state of murderous Fury 682 barged
through wall after wall with the effort
that a normal human might walk through
rice paper soon enough it was free from
the drive gray walls of the containment
site and feeling the sun on its scales
once more such a lovely day out with the
distant sound of people laughing and
chatting and children playing happily
with their pets 682 predictably found
this disgusting and resolve to destroy
them all and with all those mobile task
force operatives swigging beer eating
peanuts and giggling at amusing
celebrity cameos in Super Bowl Halftime
ads there would be nobody who would stop
682 from completing it's dastardly task
except of course one man Dr Michael
morbius while 682 was escaping morbius
was sitting on the deck of his private
yacht drinking a martini glass full of
two percent milk because morbius
understands the importance of having
healthy bones he was listening to a
fantastic podcast about the Curative
powers of beef jerky when high above the
SCP Foundation activated the morb signal
a batman-esque light shining up in the
sky in the shape of a clown this was bad
morbius paused his podcast and prepared
himself finishing the last of his milk
and washing out the glass so it didn't
get smelly he raised his arm and
summoned the morb orb a glowing red ball
that seemed to be the source of his
powers according to a number of internet
memes he clutched the orb feeling its
power flow through him as he made a
small prayer to his Guardian deity the
late David Bowie and with that he took
flight twin Jets of fire blasting out of
his shoes like rocket ships he could
only hope that he'd be able to intercept
as cp-682 before it was too late
meanwhile scp-682 was indulging in one
of his favorite hobbies just killing
lots of people he'd invaded the American
city of San Fran angliss New York which
was known for being the biggest
population of people within the
proximity of Psych 19. 682 was truly
rampaging he knocked the ice cream cones
out of children's hands causing them to
weep profusely he literally kicked dogs
and he also murdered a number of adults
with his vicious fangs and Claws the
local police attempted to stop him but
they were hopelessly outmatched they
attempted to Cuff the monster several
times only to find out that by the time
they were halfway through trying to read
the Beast it's Miranda rights he would
break free and Rampage yet again all in
all 682 was having a grand old time and
was delighted that nobody was coming to
stop its Rampage of utter Devastation it
seemed almost as though the Rampage
would never end until a dark shadow fell
over the ravenous reptilian monster it
turned up its head to see a new foe
floating above it was it a bird was it a
plane no it was Dr Michael morbius of
course wielding his trademark flaming
Trident of Justice another lamb to the
slaughter 682 growled are you ready to
meet your end Morpheus laughed and shook
his head I don't know who you are you
scaly monster but for hurting all these
innocent people you're about to get
morbid on and with that he threw his
flaming Trident at the reptile striking
Brave and true but it wasn't enough 682
had developed incredibly strong reflexes
after years of the foundation's attempts
on its life so morbius would need to try
a lot harder than just using his classic
beloved a trident to end this fight even
then before morbius had a chance to
think up another method of attack 682
had adapted and switched to the offense
two great dragon-like leathery Wings
unfurled on the monster's back and it
took to the air lunging towards morbius
with fangs born in claws at the ready
before morbius knew it the creature's
Jaws were ready to close around his head
thankfully at this moment another one of
morbius's classic superpowers comes into
play his short-range teleportation
abilities in a moment of reflex that
would impress 682 morbius teleported out
of the monster's path remanifesting
instantly floating a few feet away 682
growled in irritation of course it would
never be so easy it said the foundation
always sends one of its freaks to
distract me you may think you're strong
but really you're just another puppet
I've never heard of this Foundation
morbius quipped back and I'm not your
standard hero either I I really blur the
line between hero and villain entirely
in fact before morbius could finish
explaining what a complex character he
was if you could even use that word 682
flew after him again this time however
morbius was ready he lifted up his arms
and Unleashed another one of his
patented attacks opening up human mouths
in the palms of his hands which
Unleashed miniature yet still extremely
powerful air-to-air missiles the
missiles blasted out and struck 682
causing an impressive explosion but 682
was well versed in explosions it kept
flying after morbius he needed to get
out of here fast or he'd become a
lizard's lunch morbius turned and flew
in the opposite direction the hard to
destroy reptile hot on his heels the
first step of course would be to get
away from populated areas to limit
collateral damage no matter what
happened morbius refused to let this
mysterious entity harm more people you
cannot run forever 60 to ground your
wretched life will be brought to a slow
and painful end stranger they were
passing over the water now flying at
Quantum speeds watching the Pacific
Ocean whiz past beneath them that's when
morbius noticed it and had an epiphany a
volcano and by the looks of the smoke
Rising above it an active one too
morbius had a plan now but to execute it
he'd need perfect speed and timing he
stopped in midair as the Beast flew
towards him but moments before 682 could
make contact morevis grabbed it
executing a perfect mid-air suplex and
tossed the Roaring Beast directly down
into the volcano below for any other
monster this would be the end of it but
for 682 a double triple or even
quadruple tap was often required to
reliably incapacitate it morbius's work
was not done he flew down towards the
volcano ready to engage in the next
hectic stage of battle bet you're not
feeling so cocky now you nasty reptile
Morpheus yelled but the reptile in
question was too busy flailing around in
impossibly hot magma to reply at the
time such is the way when falling into
an active volcano
scp-682 burnt and chart but still alive
began to crawl from the top of the
volcano wheezing out smoke and Ash how
could such a strange confusing creature
have been such a formidable opponent no
matter it will destroy this Morpheus it
might just take a little longer than
expected little did the unfortunate
reptile know morbius Was preparing his
next weapon perfect for immobilizing
this ornery monster an eight ball in a
gym sock forming a kind of dangerous
makeshift flail it was the kind of
lethal improvised weapon that would
strike fear into even the strongest of
enemy combatants and now scp-682 would
learn to fear its power as the flame
broiled reptile began to stand perhaps
preparing to adapt to its latest set of
injuries morbius began relentlessly
beating the hard to destroy reptile with
the 8 ball sock dazing it with repeated
brutal strikes that never seemed to stop
morbius had learned this technique from
years of being involved in vicious bar
fights normally caused by him cheating
at darts this can stop any time you want
Morpheus yelled you just need to stop
getting back up initially 682 wanted to
remain defiant but even it could not
deny that being struck again and again
by the eight ball sock was actually
extremely painful was it really worth
the fight after performing some quick
mental calculations
scp-682 determined that no it probably
wasn't time to throw in the towel okay
okay 682 said mostly just annoyed at
this point I'll stop rampaging honestly
you just took all the fun out of it 682
just sighed and laid on the ground
exhausted slowly regenerating from its
injuries morbius smiled content with his
victory who knows how many people he'd
saved by luring this creature away from
a population Center by this point the
Super Bowl was over and the legions of
mobile task force operatives who
technically should have done this hours
ago finally decided to suit up and take
care of business it didn't take long for
Black Tactical helicopters full of
foundation soldiers to triangulate the
location of the volcano where the end of
682 and morbius's epic battle had taken
place it wasn't long after that that
there were copious Foundation boots on
the ground the story of course has a
happy ending mobile task force agents
successfully recaptured as cp682 and
returned it to its containment cell in
site 19 and in the process of recovery
they mistook Dr Michael morbius for the
actor Jared Leto and shot him roughly 30
times in the chest with armor-piercing
rounds killing him instantly want an
anomaly of your own check out
www.scpswag.com for high quality SCP
merch now go and check out scp-096
versus siren head and scp-076 able vs
chainsaw man who has the most lethal
weapon for more Wild versus battles